a viral tweet going around in fact there
are several viral tweets to the tune of
millions of views claiming that Tucker
Carlson was placed on a kill list over
his interview with Vladimir Putin man
there is a lot to break down here it's
kind of hard to title a a show like this
we only get so many characters because
it's half true and technically not true
he wasn't just placed on this list he's
been on this list for a long time
and it's not literally a kill list but
it is effectively a Target list Tucker
Carlson has already been on it because
of his interview with Vladimir Putin
naturally people are very very pissed
off and he's being accused once again of
being a Russian asset or propagandist
but the real threat right now aside from
obvious death threats and Tucker's
probably got serious security issues
because of this but the EU has actually
entertained sanctioning Tucker Carlson
over his interview with Vladimir Putin
several members of EU Parliament
Parliament have expressed their
intention to have him reviewed as it
were it it seems like a long shot but it
is very interesting and it brings up a
very interesting point which I'm going
to just say it
bluntly why does anyone care that Tucker
Carlson interviewed the president of a
country we are not at war with because
the answer is obvious we are at war with
Russia and they are now outraged that an
American journalist Tucker Carlson is
interviewing the president of a country
we are at war with and that's it I think
it's plainly obvious and it's been for a
long time most of us who've been paying
attention is that we are in this war
Chuck Schumer recently said we could
lose this war and that's why they're mad
they have unilaterally engaged in a war
without Congressional approval without
declaration and they're trying to hide
it from the American people and we all
knew but I think the sentiment is there
and it's fairly obvious so we'll talk
about that plus a bunch of other stories
are very interesting the Border bill has
been crushed that uh it's gone uh Bernie
Sanders says he won't support a bill
with Israel and now of course bro you
really got to stop really like come Ono
so far away You're sipping into the
microphone oh my bad tell me Bernie
sorry about that I've totally lost my
train of thought as you're sl slurping
three cans into the microphone I'm
clicking them off the you're slurping
into the microphone bro I'm just talking
I could totally hear you like man I
can't even I don't even know what I was
talking about Bernie uh I I'm I you I
you broke my train of thought when I was
trying to talk about Tucker Carlson I'm
like I've Lo you're cracking open cans
Bernie said he wouldn't support a bill
that before we get started my friends
welcome to the show head over to cast
brew.com and pick up your your favorite
coffee the best coffee you'll ever have
we got appalachin Knights back in stock
over uh we got ground we got uh coffee
pods for your coffee pod machine appach
night's everybody favorites and rise
with abto Jun rise with AO junor is also
available you got to sport cast through
coffee we're open up a coffee shop in
Martinsburg West Virginia you're going
to want to be there that'll be sometime
in the summer but in in the meantime if
you are a member of timcast.net
for our live event March 5th which is
about a month from now at our
Martinsburg location it is only open for
it's a private Affair you got to be a
member tickets will be made available
only to members we may only just email
out the link to buy tickets as well but
this is at at our Casper location so
many of you will get to see the building
it is the second floor so you won't see
the first floor but it's where all the
construction is happening and you'll
also get access to the members only
uncensored show which will be up tonight
at 10 p.m. and you get access to our
Discord server where you can submit
questions call in and talk to all of us
and our guest it's a lot of fun so don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight
talk about this and everything else is
Natalie Winters hi thank you so much for
having me you I know um I am the co-host
of Steve bannon's war room also an
investigative reporter and I guess since
the last time I was on I just launched
an entirely usamade lifestyle and
clothing brand called she's so right but
there also is is a men's line so it's
been fun right on she's adding
entrepreneur to her resume
congratulations thank you I'm Hannah
Clair brimo I'm a writer for cnr.com
that's scanner news I'm really grateful
to be a part of that team Ian's here I'm
the best Ian crossin on Earth what's
happening dude Tim was not lying I have
three drinks he's cracking
open reminds me of that scene from
Family Guy where Stewie's in the Attic
with an Frank and he's eating chips
really slowly and they're like what are
you doing and he's like yeah and we were
talking about Israel it's all all comes
full circle uh but they're delicious
it's two spin drifts and a kombucha I'm
going to mix them all together like The
Alchemist I am great to see you Natalie
Tim I love you Hannah CLA it's really
good to see you again it's been a while
yeah Serge what's happening Brother uh
saying you're talking about Israel and
it's something about spin drift I don't
know anyways uh I'm surge.com let's uh
get into it soon here's the first story
this one I you know initially we wanted
to talk about Tucker Carlson facing
threats of EU sanctions because we have
confirmed statements from these
parliamentary members in the EU
literally threatening Tucker Carlson
over his interview with Vladimir Putin
but then I realized the gravity of some
of these tweets you've got this tweet
from Wanita brck with 12,000 retweets
31,000 likes and 3.8 million views
followed by a quote tweet from cat turd
with 1.7 million views and 15,000
retweets wiita brck brck says this POS
dictator zalinsky has put Tucker Carlson
on a kill list for interviewing Putin
Biden has helped him with your tax
dollars this is incorrect okay cat turd
says this should disqualify this corrupt
POS from getting another dime from our
country now the challenge here is it's a
massively viral story that is half wrong
half right no no no Ukrainian government
official according to the fact check has
placed Tucker Carlson Tucker Carlson on
this list in fact this website has had
Tucker Carlson on the list going back to
August so he wasn't just placed on it
and it wasn't because of the interview
with Vladimir Putin now to be fair W de
brck did not say because uh uh or
actually no she literally did say for
interviewing interviewing Putin it
appears that there is another entry
placed because of uh following his
interview with Putin now it's not a kill
list it's a propaganda directory of some
sort a resource for pro Ukraine
individuals and the reason why I said
it's kind of half true is the fact
Checkers are trying to claim it's not a
kill list it's literally not but it kind
of is you know what I mean if you are a
high-profile individual and you appear
on this list they are basically saying
to anybody who might have access to you
you are a bad person who is working
against them and of course it has been
reported that many people who do appear
on the list do have been killed you know
and I don't know how many or the ratio
is but I do certainly think it was
important to to start with this because
because it's gone it's gone a little
little bit crazy on social media that
being said I want to highlight something
that uh you know I thought I had this
pulled up but now it's gone totally lost
come on Ian with your cans and it's
taking a sip for that one absolutely
yeah what happened to this story that we
had pull it's just gone literally gone
so you've got NBC News oh perhaps it's
right here uh we got it we got it we got
it there we go NBC news last March Iowa
police investigated a bomb threat
targeting a junior high school they
determined that the threat was a hoax
but a detective from the police
department had a theory about its
possible inspiration the libs of Tik
toac account here's here's why I want to
put these stories together okay Tucker
Carlson has been on a list since August
he has another entry addit to the list
it appears I could be wrong it could be
the same it looks different following
his interview with Vladimir Putin he
certainly is under a heightened security
threat it's probably getting death
threats these fact Checkers on the
community notes say it's not a kill list
it's not a kill list the corporate press
then claims Libs of Tik tock the same
day today is inspiring bomb threats by
targeting individuals so it's funny how
when it comes to the perceived enemies
of the establishment no no no you know I
should say yeah they're they're not
being threatened they're not aist but
when it comes to someone reporting on
and sharing information which does
create a threat to the establishment
they say you are inspiring death and
kill list they call it stochastic
terrorism this is a tactic tactic of the
left where they accuse the right when
the right says hey I am critical of your
thing they call it stochastic terrorism
then when Tucker Carlson is placed in
the crosshairs they say no it's totally
fine they're just saying you know he's a
he's he's a propagandist but the outrage
is crazy I don't know what you guys
think of uh the corporate press so far
and their entertaining posts about
Tucker Carlson and Vladimir Putin it's
complete hysteric isn't it it's kind of
wild uh I mean it's these confusing
articles that come out where they're
saying Tucker Carlson says he's the only
one who's tried to interview him you'll
get a quote from an AP report Porter
being like he does he really think he's
the only one who wants to talk to Putin
and at the same time they're sort of
condemning him for talking to Putin you
have to say what do you guys want did
you guys want to have the exclusive or
are you mad that he's doing this well
how about this any country that we have
given hundreds of billions of dollars to
I don't think we should be in a debate
over the semantics of whether or not
it's a kill list or it's some you know
government hit list and it happens to be
that Americans who have ended up on that
list have have been basically killed um
by the Ukrainian government and and I
think people don't understand the
lengths to which the regime has gone to
cover up uh what is going on in Ukraine
and I think why you're seeing these
crazy numbers in some ways I think it's
sort of the the stri and effect as as
cliche as that may sound but look they
don't want Tucker Carlson to interview
Putin I would say look no further than
the fact that it was less than a week
after Russia invaded Ukraine back in
February that the Pentagon again they
never publicly announced it but they I
believe it was The Intercept through
through Foya uh got documents showing
that they established or reestablish
Lish the influence and perception
management office which they basically
use to spread basically misinformation
and disinformation they say counter
misinformation and disinformation not
just abroad but domestically here at
home too and that's why I think you see
them in freef Fall because they've had
such a monopoly on trying particularly
to control this narrative not just
because Ukraine works as part of their
their broader Global agenda but I think
on a personnel and personal level when
you talk about you know the Biden
family's involvement there I think
Ukraine has just sort of a cash cow for
a lot of DC Elites so I think that's why
you're seeing such a a mad rush to
really keep what's going on there under
WRA the so the website my understanding
is not official uh is not affiliated
with the government officially but has
worked with law enforcement sources in
Ukraine and uh uh foreign government
sources for verification of you know
information or whatever so it's kind of
just like the fact Checkers here well
but I I would say this is this is
clearly a a uh uh information Warfare uh
asset for them listing all these people
and showing all this propaganda and
things like this and uh uh the
government uses contractors it it would
be absurd to be like oh no they're not
CIA they're just a contractor for the
CIA they're are totally private entity
they're not associated with the
government the president's not involved
they just sometimes coordinate you know
what I mean we pay the bills on occasion
but have there have there been American
citizens who were who were on this list
and killed I I believe there were or I
don't know if it was necessarily this
list but I think the whole Gonzalo lra
case I'm pretty sure he was I'd have to
imagine he's he's been on their list and
then they hunted him down and now he's
he's reportedly dead you know uh my
point is we shouldn't even be in a space
where there's gray area about whether or
not it's like a kill it regardless or if
Americans are dead or alive like for a
country that we have given so much money
to but it's not a government website so
it's but it's but I think it more or Les
I think that's like saying the
factchecking organizations here in the
United States that have been set up as
sort of outfit of ferally funded
institutions or they're receiving
federal funds it's like well I guess
they're technically not but I think
that's precisely the point they like to
be able to play that kind of shell game
say oh well it's technically not the
government but by all intents and
purposes it is it is acting in the
interest of the government probably has
some kind of you know intermediary it's
fascism it's fascism man it's why it's
so uh so hard to combat because you
can't really see it a lot of times
especially in the age of
corporatism I just love how they're
they're like it's not a kill list okay
just some people on it have been killed
there is a difference but there is a
difference that's true but it's kind of
like yo they're putting crosshairs over
I think we should be this specific if
we're going to go line by line on
whether it's a kill list or like a
Target list how about we audit all the
billions that we have sent to Ukraine
with that same level of a fine tooth
comb but these people don't actually
care about semantic they know where that
money went exactly they're never going
to audit it yeah no for real like wasn't
it wasn't it reported like half the
money they actually do not know where it
is this gone and the the best part too
speaking of how the mainstream media has
continuously Run cover on this narrative
I believe it was back in October of last
year um it was not leaked but they had
were talking with Politico from the
Biden White House saying that the new
narrative that they wanted on the
Ukraine war was that our Aid packages
over there were actually a boon to the
United States economy it was great for
the manufacturing base it was great for
jobs just the most bogus BS narrative
you've ever heard but a month two months
later you can look back at some of the
stories all these media Outlets started
running with this narrative basically
saying oh Ukraine contracts oh it's
great for you know the Eon it's great
for the defense contractors yeah I guess
it's great for the Beltway but this was
even down to like local newspapers and
like affiliate stations pumping this
very fake narrative that was
disseminating directly from the White
House if you traced it from what they
were saying in political all the way to
these newspapers so they've obviously
have been working overtime um to to
Really create this and and I think too
it's really interesting there's this
entity in DC called the US Ukraine
Business Council it's sort of like like
a lobbying group um but again they play
a little bit of semantics where they say
we technically we're not registered
foreign lobbyists but they're hosting
meetings all the time with defense
contractors but they have Sitting
members of Congress including Democratic
representative Marcy capter listed as
one of their strategic advisers so there
really is this I think I maybe like
Chinese door is that's the wrong country
sort of a good way to put it but when
you're dealing with Ukraine I think
especially now that they're that they're
at War it's like there really is no
meaningful difference I think between
what the country is doing when they're
sort of tangentially related to the
government and it not being a direct
asset of the government but frankly even
I'm sure you guys remember how FTX was
partnered I believe it was with the
ministry of digital transformation in
Ukraine that story like even if you want
to go down the route of going down
specific Ukrainian government entities
that have been caught up in corruption
there are I would say dozens of of those
avenues that you could pursue too but
the media is never going to do that so
they're just going to play word
semantics with like kill list ver not
try to kind of straw man or I guess
maybe they're still trying to Rebrand
Ukraine as a sympathetic country that is
Justified in in getting billions of
American dollars sympathetic country
like Ukraine would not be capable of
having a kill list because their
democracy right if Ukraine loses like
they are the Bastion of democracy it is
kind of funny that Ukraine is literally
the opposite of
democracy yeah they'll just kill you if
you're in the way they're suspending the
elections yeah hey when the Washington
Post said democracy dies in darkness it
wasn't a warning were telling you their
playbook that's what they want to do
well here's the other big news we have
this from scanner cnr.com EU considers
sanctioning Tucker Carlson over
interview with Vladimir Putin officials
say any sanctions would likely require
proof that Carlson is linked directly to
moscow's aggression which is a
meaningless statement because they will
just come out and be like Tucker Carlson
ran cover for Vladimir Putin lawmakers
in the EU are weighing sanctioning news
media heavyweight Tucker Carlson as a
result of his forthcoming interview with
Russian President Vladimir Putin Gremlin
spokesman Dimitri pesov confirmed Tucker
had met and talked with Putin as did the
former Fox News anchor himself in a post
to social media platform X explaining
why he sat down with the head of Russia
EU officials are considering imposing a
travel ban on Carlson who they say is
acting as a mouthpiece for Putin quote
as Putin is a war criminal and the EU
San sanctions all who assist him in that
effort it seems logical that the
external Action Service examine his case
as well there's an important takeaway
from this I mentioned it the
introduction to the show why would
anyone political celebrity personality
journalist why would anyone care that
Tucker Carlson interviewed the president
of a country we're not at war with are
they going to cry and complain xiin ping
came to California or came to the United
States no they don't care oh because the
reality is we are at war with Russia and
what's going on in Ukraine is just the
US using them as a proxy to go to war
with Russia we all know it everyone in
Europe knows it Chuck Schumer said we
could lose this war and so there it is
right in front of your face the
fascinating thing is at least when we
invaded Iraq we knew that we were going
to war they said it since then I think
the Deep State The Establishment has
just figured out don't don't say you're
going to war just do it just go here we
are it's wild I mean I think with uh
sort of we're talking about for the
rebranding of Ukraine there has also
been a a longtime narrative that Russia
is the biggest enemy we have and I think
right to bring up China uh and
especially everything all all of the
comments about the weager Muslims and
everything else that has gone on there
we definitely treat these two world
powers very differently um I think you
know it's obviously in my opinion Brave
and admirable that Tucker is going to
interview someone uh who is
controversial I think the fact that so
many European countries have said we're
going to try and shut Russia's access to
the Western World down both economically
and socially is disturbing I think they
are ultimately feeding a lot of
propaganda to their own people and if if
we're not at War then who what could
Putin say you know if he's such a
horrible person what is he going to say
that you think you can't refute in your
own media it's I if the Russians were
the aggressors and we wanted this war to
end then diplomacy would be good you
could go talk to him maybe he would stop
fighting but that they seem to not want
diplomacy which indicates that maybe
we're the aggressors here and it's kind
of like if I come up to you and I'm like
I'm not touching you I'm not touching
you I'm not touching you but I'm an inch
away from your face I'm aggressing on
you even though if you swap my hand away
I was the one that was aggressing on you
see I think they don't want transparency
I think you know they're all these
stories for a while Vladimir Putin is
super sick and he's going to die at any
second and that will cause chaos and and
Russia is going into an election year uh
if someone were to you know speak to
Putin and say are you sick you know
maybe he'd lie but at least you would
have a western Outlet asking a question
instead of it coming telephone through
Europe I think the ultimate goal is to
make it so Russia is uh too far out of
touch to for anyone to communicate with
and so you have to rely on uh agencies
like the UN or other European you know
large scale government entities to say
this is what Russia's doing believe us
don't question it at all and by the way
if all of these news outlets really hate
state-run media so much I believe I'm
not mistaken it's the New York Times I
think CNN to The Washington Post they
take money from China Daily to run
advertisements in their papers um these
have all organizations and these
journalists have all partnered with
Chinese state-run media Outlets I'm
pretty sure Tucker said that they've
reached out um to zalinsky to try to
interview him but they haven't heard
anything back but you're so right this
narrative that they're opposed to peace
talks and that you've seen at least in
whether it's the Atlantic CNN you see op
ads all the time um and it's so
interesting one of the stories that that
we were working on at War Room a lot of
the refrain that like anti peace talk
narrative even there's there was an opad
the title was like peace talks are quote
counter prod Ive which is just kind of
an asinine take in my opinion um but a
lot of those people the authors behind
it you know are are luminaries the I
always say they're like the impeachment
Witnesses of Trump's first impeachment
like the Brookings Think Tank types who
you know the elites that we should trust
um but they are all fellows and advisers
at that us Ukraine Business Council but
they never disclose those conflicts of
interest in those OP EDS so part of it I
think is the ideological compromise they
really do believe that Ukraine is like
if we don't win you know Russia Russia
Russia bad but there also is a very
clear financial interest there and I
just think it's interesting that they
never disclose that well we have one of
the greatest tweets ever in the history
of Twitter and it is here Glenn
Greenwald tweeted who were the American
journalists who conducted even minimally
adversarial interviews with zinsky to
which Elon Musk responded to be fair
it's hard for them to talk while giving
a at the same time and that may
be one of the greatest tweets ever made
and uh I had I just screenshotted it and
I had to I had to post it on X but but
as much as all all of us are laughing
and I'm sure some of you may be e muff
you know putting earm muffs on your kids
and hoping enough to explain to them
what that meant uh we do we we do have
this from end wokeness a very pressing
and important interview from CNN with
zalinsky of Ukraine I'd like to play for
you now this very very important
interview as a human
being so many people look up to you they
rely on you no one can imagine how hard
that is do you do you do anything for
your to yourself are you ever able to
take a minute
to to read or to listen to music or
something to sort of give yourself that
a moment I have such moments important
to be in silence to be alone and early
early in the morning when there are no
sounds sounds no people no no nobody I
mean the people people our stuff I mean
no okay well clearly I think they added
the music to that one but it is still
funny like wow that's I was like the
music if the music is really on that
that's amazing did they mess with the
editing to like get the close-ups of her
face looking sad cuz that is cringy well
iul yeah yeah all that's an edit the
questions from Aaron Bernett that that
is really what she's asking it is the
least adversarial thing we have ever
seen and that is what they expect start
as a human being that's what you call
humanizing someone so they're humanizing
zalinski that's a tactic that's right
and you kind well and everyone looks up
to him so it's a very fair and even
interview I mean I I don't think I've
ever looked up to zinsky I'm going to be
honest with you I'm not sure who she's
referencing here I you probably looked
down too here we go here you go zinsky
reveals his favorite band that three dog
knight uh Ukrainian I'll just play it I
think I'm pretty this yo if he likes
Three Dog I'm G him we got an ad a birth
control ad oh nice thank you thank you
CNN you got to pay hey hey hey you got
to pay your dues if you want to watch
CNN okay if you pay extra and you're one
of the rich ones they won't force feed
this birth control commercials down your
throat what is that I don't know what it
was it might not birth control it was
fizer people look up to you they rely on
you no one can imagine how hard that is
do
you do you do anything for your to
yourself are you ever able to take a
minute
to to read or to listen mus or something
to a moment I have such moments
important to be in silence to be alone
alone uh how can I be alone alone I can
be with with music is through or with
the book and early early in the morning
when there are no sounds sounds in no a
no no people no no nobody I mean the
people people our stuff I mean blah blah
blah I don't care to hear this I want
who who's his favorite band what is it
says classic rock did he do he name
anything they want to make you watch
this video I hope Tucker asked Vladimir
Putin the same exact question for btim
he's like the be's that' be the no who's
going to name a Russian this guy's going
to name a an American band or like a
European band they're they're different
people completely it's such a scop even
down to like what he's wearing right he
always has to be ready for battle he
never takes off this uniform even though
when he's traveling he's nowhere near
any Battlefield like I don't think he's
ever anywhere near the battlefield
that's true I think this guy is a TV
character he is yeah I mean he literally
was he played the president on TV but I
think he I I don't think this guy's ever
seen anything close to conflict they
they probably have in a secure location
because he's basically uh you guys you
guys have seen Hunger Games right yeah
in the second one when they get Katniss
out you know of the games they're like
keep her in the basement and have her
make videos they don't want her going to
war because if she dies she's the
propaganda tool she's a rallying cry
that's what they're trying to do with
this guy I gotta be honest he's the
least inspiring guy they could have
gotten I mean seriously couldn't they
have gotten some like Dolph lungren like
type Ukrainian dude who's like filming
prop propo videos on the front line
Ukrainian chick is that I was going to
say which one was hden tried that with a
trans woman and that was like but but it
was to Pander to the Liberals in the
left in the United States so they could
ask for money yeah I say who was Hayden
paner married to she was married to a
Ukrainian guy who was like I'm going to
the fields or whatever else like much
better than Z they need like a 6 fo5
ripped dude who's standing there you
know holding a weapon being like as the
president I will make sure and then they
film fake videos where he's on the front
line leading the troops this is just
some guy who's in a park all the time
and he's like not doing anything well he
walks around places that seem staged and
well lit looking sort of sad and pensive
and so really in that sense he's doing
exactly what they need him to remember
remember that video that came out where
the background was completely still and
the trees weren't moving in the wind and
they were like people were like yo this
looks like a green screen and they were
no no it's not it's not a green screen
what are you talking about you don't
understand Ukraine in our culture our
trees don't move in the wind there is no
Russia has stolen our
wind the trees can't blow because
they're mad at Russia that's the that's
the state of the world I they're still
in protest for the things that we're
suffering like it just becomes so
ridiculous and I think you're right the
amount of money that we're spending on
Ukraine considering this is this is what
they're doing which is just a sort of
take a he has gone on so many
International trips being like please
money he's like a professional
fundraiser for his country and it seems
crazy that when Tucker Carlson is like
well I want to talk to the other side
everyone's like how could you do this
possible sanctions like you know
hysterics I just had an idea for
something I would love to make if we had
the means and it's like you take that
scene and then halfway through you just
zoom in on zilinsky and Aaron brunette
and you play like slowly increasing
romantic music with no with no dialogue
and they're just looking at each other
and then it escalates there are some
rtic undertones right but then you have
the Dolph lungren Style guy and you will
film a different scene where he comes in
and goes zinsky get away from her She's
Mine you yeah ptin he comes in he's like
you cannot have her she is mine and then
uh it just soap opera style you know and
then Aaron berett is like Putin you
can't be here you you died in that
Safari when your brother contracted
malaria and then gave it to you no I
survived with this and then he holds up
like a golden the the the uh the Holy
Grail didn't Justin Trudeau try to make
fun of Putin he was at some
International Gathering of whoever cares
uh and there were these photos of like
Putin shirtless on Horseback that had
come out you know a little you know
whatever man like a little try hard but
okay and Justin Trudeau tried to make
fun of for them he's like maybe we
should all take it was just like the
most ridiculous obvious jealousy uh I
just find the hysterics around this
whole thing deeply confusing and I think
ultimately trying to make Putin the bad
guy is the only way they can try to keep
the narrative going of this is something
Americans should pay attention to well
it's because we're at War I'm if if if
Tucker Carlson interviewed like I don't
know the the president of you know
Tajikistan or something or what I don't
even that I don't even know if they have
a president nobody would care they'd be
like uh whatever but Tucker Carlson
interviewed Vladimir Putin and we're at
war with Russia so naturally they're
freaking out I want to know why I still
want to know why we're still at War so
was it to to diminish Russia's power or
is it to take control of the region is
it both I mean it would be a both thing
well it's both like is it really like to
full military Global dominance right now
because they're trying to do this new
world order thing where they have all of
us kind of technocratic bow to our
Overlord but like why don't they just
get the US Russia to go along with it I
don't understand why they're making him
fight Russia's well it it could be that
Russia it's all fake conflict I don't
know I also just think it's such a
double standard I know I make everything
about about China that's the the War
Room rubbing off on me but um you know
it is really hypocritical what was it
just one or two months ago that you know
you have xijin ping right coming to San
Francisco getting the red carpet rolled
out for him and I think you make the
point precisely it's like we're
basically at at War right Russia Ukraine
that's why it's okay not that's why it's
not okay for Tucker to interview Putin
so then China's obviously at war with us
yeah it's not necessarily kinetic it's
more of the unrestricted Warfare type
certainly information Warfare so then
why is it okay to have XI Jin ping on
American soil and R roll out the red
carpet for him and have media Outlets
interview him and have them take cash
from Chinese Communist party it's just
it's such a double standard and it's
goes back to the original premise which
that it's all about narrative control
and suppression well perhaps what will
happen come November is Donald Trump
wins but in the meantime let's jump to
this very hilarious story from NBC News
Nikki Haley loses to none of these
candidates in the Nevada GOP Primary
that's right Nikki Haley was running in
the primary she took it very very
seriously she did wait till wait wait
till you see the clip we're going to
play from an interview and uh she lost
To None that's right she lost to No One
quite literally like no one beat her no
no no like quote no one end quote beat
beat her like when people were given the
choice between Nikki Haley and someone
else anybody please not her somebody
anybody please not her one mhm and so
it's been an excellent day of memes
Andrew claven said uh don't make fun of
her for losing to none of these
candidates none of these candidates ran
a great campaign and none of these
candidates is qualified to be the
president of the United States very
clever but um where's that uh here we go
let me let me play this clip for you so
you can hear it for yourself what she
had to say does that situation Nevada
hurt a little bit no I mean Nevada it's
such a scam they were supposed to have a
primary Trump rigged it so that the GOP
chairman who's been indicted would go
and create a caucus we knew months ago
that we weren't going to spend a day or
a dollar in Nevada because it wasn't
worth it and so we didn't even count
Nevada that wasn't anything we were
looking at we knew that was rigged oh I
love oh it was rigged from the start it
was rigged from the start Trump rigged
it she's an election Den I I just love
this so much because she's like it's
it's qu like we should stop saying sour
grapes and start saying Nikki losing in
Nevada because she's just like I didn't
want to win the primary anyway like who
cares it was rigged it was so dumb we
didn't want it it is actually dumb
because she took it seriously enough to
register to be on the ballot despite the
fact that the RNC is awarding based off
the caucus which is tomorrow like she is
now saying I know I'm going to lose in
the caucus and Nevada so she's getting
out ahead of the message of like well
not only did you lose to literally no
one you also lost to Trump she's saying
it never mattered which how could you
like her if you're a Nevada voter but
you know that if she did get first place
and none of these candidates didn't
didn't make a mark she'd be saying look
that's Trump's fault I won the Primary
those delegates are mine blah blah blah
instead she you lose yeah is it Z rigged
it he rigged it yeah he rigged it he
rigged it she's banging she said it
twice I think she did um she did she
probably say it more I stopped the video
26 seconds in are is it's Nevada zero
delegates is that what I was reading
zero I thought they said it had zero
delegates for the primary oh okay yeah
the caucus they're they're doing a
caucus to award I think what is it what
what is that it's because they want to
remove his name from The Ballot or
something or what that's why they moved
to a caucus yeah I mean so Nevada is
weird because they tried really hard to
say like in 2021 they passed this law
saying we are actually the state that
gets to hold the first of the nation uh
caucus or first of the nation primary
and they had been from what I understand
a caucus system beforehand and uh this
is all leading into the time where the
Democratic party spent a lot of time
saying actually we want to rework the
entire schedule we don't want Iowa and
New Hampshire to go first we don't think
it represents the vo voter base
basically saying they're not diverse
enough States and so they want to lead
with South Carolina and Nevada and go
into a different schedule and so you're
seeing this year uh Republicans having
races in some states and sometimes
they're held at the same time as
Democrats and other times they're not so
like the South Carolina primary for the
Democrats was uh February 3rd but the
South Carolina primary for the
Republican is I think it's February 26th
right at the end of the month uh so
because their parties are operating
differently just like so the Republican
saying well even though you have now
passed a state law saying you have to
have a primary we are still having the
caucus and that's what we're Waring is
very similar to what um the Democrats
did in New Hampshire which is to say
even though it's state law there you
have to have the first and the nation
primary they they discouraged the
Democratic uh New Hampshire Democrats
from holding one and they said if you do
we won't award any delegates based on
that so you're just seeing this
bifurcation of we want to control the
order in which states vote I I just
pulled it up the the issue is that they
passed a law in 2021 to uh get rid of
the caucuses the Republicans said that's
ridiculous primaries are not secure and
they said no and they said well we're
only counting the caucuses anyway yeah
so the RNC is is taking authority over
the states basically well the state can
do they can say whatever they want but
the part is private yeah both parties
are doing this like if you look at New
Hampshire the Democrat National the
Democrat the DNC was like we're not
counting your primary votes because you
are not obeying our order and the
Republicans said to Dada we don't care
that you want to hold a primary we want
a caucus here that's what we've always
done and so it it's weird it's unusual
on the other hand I think it just shows
how much people don't trust the voter
system I mean what the Democrats are
selling right now is that if we follow
the old order we're basically following
racism they have said Andrew Biden has
uh endorsed this that we have to change
the order of the States they're really
drifting far apart I I I just I have a I
have a real question there's a real real
one I I what would possess Nikki Haley
into
figuratively standing in public and
begging people to throw spoiled rotten
garbage at her I mean like this is one
of the most humiliating things a person
could personally ask for so apparently
she's not going to be in the caucus her
name's not in the caucus she's only in
the primary and she lost to none of
these candidates I I wonder if she
actually thought she was going to win
she's like with Trump not in the ballot
I get first place and then she doesn't
and she gets beat by literally any like
just not her does it mean that they
wrote his name in that's basically no no
one of the options was none of these
candidates you could vote for none of
these candidates literally and and none
beat Nikki
Haley dou was it was double I feel like
this spin I mean it just reeks of
insincerity and probably you know focus
group sessions of all of her big
corporate and Democrat donors but
they're like what is the Trump BAS
really like talk about you know rigged
elections so that's what we're going to
say we're going to try to like pull the
trump card and be like oh it was rigged
oh we didn't even like it's sort there's
something sort of like Trump esque about
right the way that she's approaching go
on the offense you have to attack
exactly but like it doesn't work cuz no
one actually likes you and you actually
lost well she's an election denier now
she is she should join the
club Joe Lombardo was one of the first
people at least I saw I'm sure other
people had said it who had said you know
I am going to partake in the primary
because that's what's happening our
state but I'm going to vote for none of
none of these candidates because I I
don't want anyone here I'm he's been
always been a really big supporter of
trump and so I just think Nikki Haley
was hoping that there were I think she
miss she underestimated the support that
Trump has on the populace level
especially among State Governors I mean
not even the governor of her own State
South Carolina which is basically the
next thing that she's leading up to
saying I hope I can win South Carolina
none of the Republicans in South Carol
the entire admin like the entire
administration of government like all
the Republicans just endorse Trump
everybody but I don't even think the
variable here is like Nikki Haley and
what she thinks is politically wise for
her to do it's the donors who are
propping her up she's more or less uh to
quote someone a listless vessel and I
think that's right I think that she it's
not about actually analyzing like boots
on the ground voters it doesn't matter
because she's not she knows she's not
going to win deep down to her cour you
think she have she'd have enough
self-esteem to be like I don't want to
be the puppet beh in front of all of
this and be humiliated like this like
she's saying stuff now that she's never
going to take be able to take back and
it just shows how unpopular she is I
mean where does she go in terms of her
political career after being wrecked
over and over again she'll run in
26 or whatever I just like I I I just
the most embarrassing thing person could
stand her foreign policy how okay with
losing all this I I I just I'm sorry
like the humiliation the humiliation
that she's experiencing and you can see
it in her face like no it doesn't matter
we didn't even care like we didn't even
want to be in Nevada you know Trump
rigged it he rigged it I didn't even
hold on I can't enough to register but I
don't actually care at all whoa whoa
whoa whoa which is it did you always
know you were never going to spend any
money in Nevada or are you upset that
Trump rigged it and you actually wanted
to win and you got your name on the
ballot I think she thought she was going
to get it for sure and then instead she
just got a like she was just standing
right between the the sewage pipe and
right in public in front of everybody
and she's standing there going I didn't
want to stand here in the first place
you're all dumb I didn't I didn't want
to spend money it's like dude it's not
that sour grapes like to say that people
have short memories is kind of vague
generalization it's not always true some
people have great memories but a lot of
people reading the past history and
watching the patterns they don't they
forget like Joe Biden resigned from his
run for president in 19 in 1988 because
he was plagiarizing humiliation no you
should never have a guy like that in
office but people whatever reason for
got I was never told I had to find out
through you know securest means
eventually in 2009 or something so I
think she's going to be groomed to run
with somebody's VP in 2008 28 or 32
they're just they're going to keep her
around and now this is good all
publicity is good publicity crap it's
not it's all good all publicity is not
good publicity not with the Internet
it's a little different with internet
video it's it's different like this this
is bad for her brand it turns her into a
clown like holy crap I got to say man
you know the pr people know such thing
as bad press I'm like I kind of think
there is like you losing To None
basically makes you the least viable
candidate ever this point moving on like
who you you can't run for anything you
can't run for for class president at
this point you can't run for the what
federal position is available to her
right now because she's not going to get
a position in the Trump Administration
that's just the way it is and you know
she's not super welcome in her home
state you'll hear interviews with South
Carolina voters who say you know she was
a great Governor I just don't see her as
president whatever else but now it seems
like the voters who have elected the
current guard of leaders in South
Carolina wouldn't support her either I
mean they have drifted more favorably
towards Trump the longer she stays in
this battle with Trump the more she
isolates herself from most Republican
voters but I think she's more concerned
about what the defense Contracting
industry thinks of her and what C she
gigs and retainer fees she'll be able to
get I don't think she gives a I won't
cuss but anything about Republican baser
she wouldn't have first of all stepped
in she would have stepped out a while
ago and I think it's just sort of
performative uh activism I would say to
get a cushy gig at whether it's Ron
Boeing choose your corporate you know
sugar but she already had those I mean
she could have stay she is choosing to
go back into politics because she craves
the power is my assumption I feel like
she's being pushed like she's sitting in
a driver's seat of a self-driving car
well Ken Griffin gave her what he gave a
super pack like $5 million but then he
was interviewed and he was like yeah I
don't think she's she's going to win so
uh but it's not I think why it comes off
so disingenuous is that they're not
giving money to her because they
actually liked her Ronda santis was sort
of the first pick but then he obviously
was the sacrificial lamb it didn't work
out then maybe it was going to be Glenn
Yan now it's Nikki Haley so I think
there's that lack of authenticity
because they don't actually believe in
her it's just the way things have sort
of happened the way the the tables have
turned the cards have played it's like
she's the last one standing and yeah
maybe she's a woman so it makes them
feel better but I don't I don't really
think there's like I said she's a
listless vessel for these corporate
donors who oftentimes are are majority
Democrat but she's just sort of a
walking shell of their interests you
think those people care about the Maga
base the Republican base they're
probably laughing oh these dumb idiots
are going to think if we say the word
rigged let's focus group that word like
that's going to go over with them
because they're really into election
denialism but it shows you how to touch
they are I will give her credit she
learned how to talk while opening and
closing her mouth it was funny because I
tweeted like Nikki Haley when she speaks
she doesn't move her teeth and then it
was It was kind of wild because they
were people like they got to be PR
account something defending her saying
your teeth don't move when you talk and
I was like dude your mouth opens and
closes and your teeth are going up and
down but when she talks she keeps her
jaw still and she talks through her lips
like this it's like she's yelling at her
dog you know what I mean like you know
you're dog that's the adjective tur is
that what you're
doing how dare you I will lock my teeth
together you got a garbage against her
energy Style tur but in this I I noticed
she looks tur I don't know figured out
how to speak with uh opening and closing
her mouth which she laughed nervously in
the beginning of the interview tell
she's a mess right now what is Nikki you
go got to drop out nikk sorry nimada so
these people that are funding her
campaign are they basically ready to
profit off of global organization like
Global Finance if if the US amalgam is
into this new world order thing just
just try and understand it you know Ian
I think I think you're too self-centered
I think you got to understand it from
their perspective if someone came to you
and said blowing up a bunch of kids
would put a million bucks in your pocket
you'd say yes right I don't think so you
got but you got I'd like to hear more
about the plan before I try and hear it
from her donor's perspective you know
what I mean like you blow up a bunch of
kids over there and you get money over
here okay right that's the argument okay
I'll I'll play along I'll smly Butler
this tell me morly Butler this why would
anyone in their right mind like I guess
they just love blowing up why they are
would support this this is what I'm
wondering I think they a lot of people
that are are down are ready to profit on
the transfer of power from the American
Le uh economic order to the new global
economic order and they're like we're
going to make so much money off our
Black Rock Investments off of they
already are and so if Nikki so they're
willing to put five million behind Nikki
because she's probably would I would
imagine passively go along with it where
Trump they all want to be the one who
has a president who's in their pocket
right I mean you want to be able to call
on the favors that's that's really why a
lot of people donate to political
campaigns to ultimately have influence
over the candidate that's exactly what
we're see going on right right now on
the hill right with this immigration
Bill like most American people I think
immigration is the issue that we're
probably gaslit the hardest on but most
average Americans have absolutely no
demonal benefit from allowing illegal
immigration right it's a wage killer
doesn't make our cities safer but those
same people who are donating to Nikki
Haley's campaign they love the open
border they love the cheap labor right
they don't believe in sovereignty I also
believe there's an element of
ideological compromise too but I think
for so long we've been accustomed to
politics where there's really no
meaningful difference between Republic
and Democrat right whether it's the unip
party critique or however you want to
perceive of it but I I really think
that's why Trump was so transformational
because he changed that and made the
Republican Party really a party of the
working class and even you see punch
Bow's sort of analysis of what happened
on the hill today specifically on that
border bill they said it was the death
of the old Republican party right it was
so long you know it used to be McConnell
could get his you know watered down
conservative border bills passed because
there wasn't meaningful push back and I
think the Nikki Haley of the world the
Ronda santis of the world it's sort of
that Deja Vu to that like pre 20106 era
politics where all of the Republican
politics it was politicians it was like
let's just choose do we want to bomb
Iraq or Syria and how many kids do we
want to kill it was basically just like
picking the same style of just basically
neoconservatism and I think that's why
she's not going over well well but that
dying guard of donor they're not ready
to give up yet right they don't they
don't roll over without a fight and I
would not want Nikki Haley to be my
fighter even if she's wearing heels as
I'm sure she'd be uh more than certain
to point out it's her ammo though I
don't know what that means but that's
what she said her heels honestly I have
to say as a someone from La very into
fashion like her heels aren't even cute
like I don't know if I were going down
the heel fighting W they're ugly do you
sell heels with your company no we don't
do shoes mainly uh accessories and
clothing but uh hey I I would send Nikki
Haley some clothes help would you ADV on
her campaign um well most of our designs
are like America First and uh low social
credit score so I don't know she'd be
into that cuz I don't really think uh
she believes in let's jump to this story
from cnr.com large majority of
Republicans support the idea of trump
being a dictator for a day you know the
funny thing is Trump didn't actually say
he would in the literal sense he was
just like when he was asked he said only
on day one and so he could drill for oil
and it's and secure the border and it's
like okay what what what people are
actually suggesting is that you just go
and arrest everybody military tribunals
I think Roseanne asked for 74% majority
of Republican voters say they support
the idea of former president Donald
Trump being a dictator for a day if he's
reelected a new survey from the
University of Massachusetts Amer and
yugov found 36% of independent voters
also support the prospect wow I don't I
support Donald Trump using his legal
Authority which he already has and
doesn't need to be a dictator to start
getting rid of the corruption I want
evidence I want criminal trials we don't
need a dictator just to go in and and
start deciding who should and shouldn't
be I want the public to see the evidence
I want it to be historic I want it to be
documented I want there to be a book a
Wikipedia entry talking all about all
the evidence that was uncovered and how
Donald Trump got an AG in there and
cleaned this place up I like the
hysteria around the Donald Trump uh
dictator for day Comet because it's like
they're just hooked on cartoons and
they're expecting the villain to be like
well my plan is to become a dictator
like you think someone who actually
wants to be a dictator leads with I'm
going to be a dictator well but to be to
be fair it's the distinction between
cartoons for 10-year-olds and C well
actually cartoons for 5-year-olds and
cartoons for 10-year-olds the cartoons
for 10-year-olds are a little bit more
sophisticated than that like I I
mentioned this before it's a great line
from Justice League where Lex Luther the
super villain is running for president
and when one of the Justice League
confronts him a character called the
question Luther Luther says do you have
any idea how much power I would have to
give up in order to be president it's
like even 10-year-olds understand the
the the context there and the these
people are thinking like it's it's it's
like they're five and the villain's like
I'm going to freeze the Earth yeah
snidle Whiplash you guys ever watch that
no was um bull Rocky and Bullwinkle
that's some pretty basic stuff it was
right in your face snidle was like the
guy like he say I'm going to be a
dictator he was always like the villain
you know he's twirling his mustache
literally I got to tell you cuz this
this you know I on the story all week by
this guy I met in uh in DC quite
literally told me just you wait when
Donald Trump gets elected you will lose
all your rights I'm like bro projection
it's projection though I think Joe Biden
is I mean cliche but the true dictator
you look at whether it's the
weaponization of the doj the laware the
way the way that they're conducting
Global Affairs it's clearly just
projection and I think the old way that
they did the projection Playbook was
sort of the Russia Russia Russia like
foreign collusion because obviously the
Democratic party and of course
establishment Republicans sto but are
always colluding with foreign foreign
governments but I think they know the
Russia Trope is sort of used up I think
you used to see the like black lives
matter stuff always pop up right before
elections right that's I think they
realize that like ad Homen and racist
attacks don't work as much anymore and
now I think they're really going down
they have like two I would say
concurrent strategies one is like the oh
democracy is going to die in die in
darkness and Trump is a dictator oh even
you know appeal to like the neocons like
Oh we must preserve our our way of life
but I also think the sort of other other
route that they're going down um
is I don't know I think it's really just
like I don't know it's just it's just
always projection and it's I don't know
it's it's it's just the same it's like
you could do that with every story I
kind of think we're headed towards a
wartime presidency as many people try to
refer to it I don't know what to do I
don't know how you solve this problem
but a bifurcated culture a
post-modernist and a you know like
traditional American Republican IST
World they can't coexist and so I don't
think it's a matter of what anyone wants
to happen it it doesn't matter if you
want Trump to be dictator or not there
will come a point where there is no
question yeah you're not allowed to ask
Trump will not decide it will just be in
front of you when you when you when you
face down with like far- leftists trying
to seize territory in cities like they
did in 2020 shooting and killing people
eventually get to the point where you're
like then we have to have armed guards
and creating checkpoints it's not a
question of I would like or I would not
like when the far if the far-left
violence exceeds a certain degree there
will be a response and and then you'll
walk down the street and you're going to
have National Guard and they're going to
be like you know you need an ID and your
whatever and you're going to be like
this is dictatorship and they're going
to be like okay if we leave the far
leftists will come in with their guns
again and then what do you do cre abl
like what is it the like thesis
antithesis synthesis whatever that is
it's like I think the reason why I think
there is some truth to this poll in the
sense that Joe Biden is such a weak man
Trump is such a strong man and I think
when you look around the country and you
see particularly what's going on at the
southern border I mean I think you make
a valid case for wanting a a a a strong
leader who's actually going to protect
National sovereignty and I think in some
ways it sort of reflects that that
longing that yearning for like America
to be a country again with a leader with
a government that actually does
something to fight for the people and
it's not all totally decentralized and
sent out to all these like swampy
bureaucratic agencies like I think from
a social perspective the the desire for
a dictator there is something
interesting there in terms of how it
interplays with I think think a lot of
the critiques we hear of like
decentralizing and deconstructing the
administrative state right because that
really is the way of diffusing power to
unelected bureaucrats and I don't know
about you I personally would rather have
dictator Trump than than president Trump
uh compounded with you know like
bureaucrat you know overlord fouchy and
Millie and that's probably it yeah when
when it comes to this question people
are probably saying there is too much
corruption in DC it is a swamp and you
need someone to just go in and drain it
if you don't know how to solve the
problem you may lash out at stupid
Solutions because you just want to get
this problem over with like if the
problem is deep State corruption that's
a big problem how do you solve it well a
lot of people are like I don't know best
thing I can think of is some guy goes in
and does it but like there's ways to do
it technical ways to do it you just got
to have control of power sources you got
to have control of uh mass media like
Airwaves like radio waves and stuff like
that if you have your own satellites
things like that you can kind of
maintain open systems where information
can be traded um behaviors can become
transparent and then I think the system
kind of solves
itself I I think part of why people who
support Trump understood that the
dictator comment was more about I'm
going to take action immediately is
because they're tired of the way that
the Biden Administration does uh
Implement authoritarian culture while
pretending they're for you they're
pretending they're for democracy and I
think the idea that someone would be
direct be like yes on the first day I'm
immediately going to do these things is
refreshing it's appealing like you're
saying it's an appeal to strength and I
think uh the you know Biden is
notoriously unpopular and he doesn't
have the approval ratings that really I
think would predict an easy win to
reelection uh and so ultimately Trump by
just being direct saying these are these
are the problems you're facing and I'm
going to fix them and if I have to be uh
you know if I have to make that my
number one priority from day one I will
do that for you makes people feel like
they can trust him to change whereas the
Biden Administration is sort of always
saying a lot of things and doing nothing
I mean right to talk about the Border
they they initially with all of the
Razer wire stuff said you have to pull
the Razer wire out because it's inhumane
and people will drowned and they're like
that's why I put it Texas says that's
why I put it there because we don't want
people to swim across the river it's
dangerous at which point the Biden
region said actually you needed our
approval for that and that's why you
have to take it out I mean the Biden
Administration is ultimately trying to
keep the borders open and they want
there to be a flow of illegal
immigration into the country but they
won't just say that and so that fact
that someone be like yes I would be a
dictator to change to to turn the ship
to make things right I think freaks out
people who know ultimately Trump has the
same values as them and wouldn't be a
dictator as opposed to someone who is
constantly saying no no I have your
values but I'm lying to you constantly
and doing things doing one thing
claiming to be doing another yeah they
um because if you say I'm not a dictator
but you're signing executive orders over
and over and over then you are a
dictator and you're lying to people yeah
I'm not a dictator but you all have to
wear masks I'm not a dictator but you
have to leave the military if you don't
get the vaccination I'm not a dictator
but I'm going to fight the state's
rights to defend itself until I I you
know am left at the point where states
are starting to turn against me I'm not
a dictator you are but I'm actually
going to do everything I can to maintain
as much power and be disrupted as I'm
not a dictator but my family is going to
profit millions of dollars off of
contracts with China and Ukraine I'm not
a dictator but my son's going to get a
really really ple deal until you guys
catch it and I have to sort of pretend
otherwise I got like two thoughts one is
Trump he kind of got caught out of
context saying that he was going to be a
dictator on day one they asked him in
that interview are you going to be a
dictator un and he's like not even
listening he's like only on day one I'm
going to close the border was joking
yeah and he wasn't really even answering
the question they asked he was just like
on day one I'm going to do some extreme
stuff but this fervor for that even
people would consider wanting this
dictatorship in any way as like Roman
Republic stuff I mean Julius Caesar came
back with his troops and established a
dictatorship because the Republic was so
was it 200 years of prosperity well they
wrote the history books so it's tough to
tell and I'm sure the Roman the rich
Romans were getting on very good but
there's no way for 200 years you
suppress dissent from people fleeing the
country especially in that era man I
have no idea they wrote all those
history books it's tough to tell they
just conquered and conquered yeah but
anybody could go could just leave and be
like here's what happened and people
would know you know what I mean like it
would be within the writings of all
neighboring Nations whatever that it was
terrible within the Roman Empire there
was no Prosperity I don't I don't hear a
lot about the brutality of the Roman I
know that they were brutal to the
non-romans to the to the sub citizens
you know the slave class and the the
foreigners that Liv there but they don't
talk a lot about it in the history books
at least not the ones I've been reading
he we we we've we have talked about this
quite a bit that are we in the collapse
of the Roman Empire or the start of the
Roman Empire yeah it's like the Republic
is sh is shuttering I would say um that
doesn't mean it's going to fall apart
necessarily but it feels like it the
walls are shaking right now and like
whoa what's that green ooze pouring out
of the walls how long has that been in
there years an attempt on Trump's life
and it causes him like disfiguration to
his right side but he also has to use
like a voice box so he's wearing like a
mask and then he's just like I have
dissolved the Senate this is the new
American Empire yeah no mace windo
heroics we don't need any of that um I
we've got to I mean I don't know man I
don't know if if it's cyclical if
there's anything we can do to help stop
the or make it better I'm sure there is
just going to be better the transition
from the American Republic into the New
World Order like it's it's going to be
we're part of a bigger global system now
the Republic's got some awesome ideals
and if we can Inspire Free Speech all
over the globe that could be part of the
system that's not part of the the global
agenda corporations don't like free
speech they want the owner of the
corporation to run the show that's the
problem I think part of the reason that
they have been so adamantly opposed to
Trump winning this year and they've
really I think ratcheted up the attacks
particularly on the law fair front I
think if you look at a lot of these kind
of global agendas whether it's like the
UN and their sustainable development
goals the world economic forum and the
great reset um a lot of you're even the
ma in China 2025 initiative but a lot of
these kind of Master plans I would say
the kind of ideological underpinning or
framework like if you really drill down
as to what actually constitutes the new
world order they're all set to conclude
in 2030 and I think if you you know do
the math right 2025 the term would start
it ends 2029 a trump term now it's like
a second third Trump term would be
absolutely I mean a death Nowell I think
in some ways you could argue for a lot
or at least a strong impediment to the
for their ability to really roll out a
lot of these Global agendas and I think
that's why they are in such heavy full
out panic mode um about ensuring that
Trump doesn't win this election yeah and
I think that's backed up by the way he
ripped up the trans-pacific partnership
day three after he got in was like we're
not sell the wh I think you you know
that you can definitely make the case
that he could have done more but put it
this way if the only person in between
us becoming you know New World Order wh
WF un slaves uh would you rather have it
be Donald Trump Nikki Haley or Joe Biden
well I know Trump a little better I know
the people that know him anyway and I'd
like to hang out with him but I think
that if he starts the if he starts
saying like yo we all want a new world
or this American Military Base
everywhere stomping on the neck of of
humanity is not good anymore let's
figure out a better way if he was like
open he like we're going to make a new
world order and it's going to have
American ideals at the center of it a
new world order with American
nationalism economic nationalism but I
don't think I think I I mean I'm not
speaking on behalf of trump but his
conception I think particularly if you
look at how he has reformed the
Republican Party putting back in that
economic nationalist populist
perspective at the the Bedrock of that
is sovereignty and the Bedrock of
sovereignty is borders and that concept
of borders and nation states whether
it's the West failan Nation system or or
what we should have here with a secure
Southern border that is fundamentally at
odds with the concept that these new
world order type groups are pushing
which is global government right because
that implies that we're Global Citizens
and that there's a global Sovereign and
I don't think that Donald Trump or the
kind of new version of the Maga
Republican party believes in that to any
extent and I would say look no further
than the fact that the the guy who was
advising The Who on drafting a lot of
the pretext to the current pandemic
treaty that they're debating was Joe
Biden's taught bioh health um advisor so
there's this very very icky overlap
between a lot of the whoos that even Joe
Biden's supply chain sustainability
coordinator is like a world economic
form Alum so all of these people have
like weasel their way in to really I was
going to say subvert but it's not to
subvert the Biden regime it's to amplify
um and I think to really complement what
what is this idea of global government
this idea that being an American doesn't
mean anything look no further than the
fact that in New York they're handing
out IDs to illegal aliens that is like
such a metaphorical example of what it
what American citizenship means to these
people and it means nothing because they
don't believe in borders because they're
globalists to their core let's jump to
with a hard segue to some cultural news
because this one's awesome Shane Gillis
is going to be hosting SNL on Saturday
and this is important for all of you
because he was fired by Saturday Night
Live in 2019 for surfaced jokes he had
made on podcasts many years prior where
I think he did like an Asian accent and
he made what they called homophobic
jokes so SNL said you fired you can't
work here anymore now considering many
see him as the you know upand cominging
star in the comedy circuit one of the
funniest comedians in the world SNL
asked him to host and once again the
woke machine is trying to cancel him but
oh it's so funny it's not working NBC
News writes with Shane Gillis return to
SNL Asians ask when they'll stop being
the punchline I just love this so much I
I don't count everybody knows that I
don't count but you know if I were to
agree with them I would so first I'll
say I agree with the woke left on
discrimination and all that stuff now as
officially an Asian person because I
agreed with you don't forget um I'm not
asking this question at all quite
literally don't care if he does an Asian
accent people do it all the time I'm not
going to cry and winge about South Park
in fact I love the CityWalk guy he's
great we all love him it turns out he's
a white guy the whole time did you guys
ever watch that one no it turns out he
the CityWalk guy was like the Chinese
guy at the Chinese food restaurant so it
was okay that CHS made fun of it then
right he didn't make fun of that but it
turned out you know the South Park guys
canonically he yeah canonically he's
actually a white guy who's got like what
do he like get a frenic or something I
think there are like levels of
comedianshulerking just listened to
Shane gillis's podcast with um theovon
and I don't follow his standup very much
so I don't know what he's like normally
but it was definitely interesting during
the episode hearing him be like oh you
got to be careful like you're not
supposed to say stuff like that it seems
like cancel culture has definitely had
an effect on him yeah and I mean maybe
it it's a confidence boost to be able to
go back on a show that was that fired
you uh over something you had you know
you couldn't take back and you kind of
had no control over it that really made
his career though to be honest and I
know that he recognizes that too but
that it's funny bring that uh particular
podcast if anyone wants to go watch it
because uh Theo Von brings up a lot of
points about this exact thing within the
whole comedy world and it's uh and this
whole like being cancelled people that
don't even really care about what you do
and don't even like the stuff that
you're putting out in the world in the
first place they're not going to drop
him from hosting I'm willing I'm willing
to bet then when I bet he's got I bet
he's got a contractual agreement I bet
they were like we want you to host and
he was like okay but you can't cancel
like cuz people are going to be pissed
and they're like no we get it there's no
way SNL did not know this is we are
winning so massively that SNL is now
doing a turn around was didn't they fire
nor McDonald yeah there was some other
moment where like and then he hosted and
he was like you know I got fired from
the show for not being funny yeah he's
amazing look at this this is the
collapse of of woke dominance in in in
the media there's this other big news
that they're going to have they're going
to they're they're they're recasting
Pirates of the Caribbean for a younger
cast and they're going to have the main
character played by like a young black
woman and this one's interesting because
it's like it's a hand me down mhm this
it's not going to work it's
condescending it's insulting I we we
were talking about this like eight years
ago with when they were try and race
swap characters you're taking you're
taking a character that is beloved and
known who is like a white dude and then
it's a hand me- down character like oh
yeah by the way well we make him black
and a woman and and and now you've got a
character it's like no you didn't make
an original character I feel like that's
way more insulting to say we'll just
sort of recycle something else also sort
of unfair because that depiction of um
of camj is so iconic I mean people
really loved it that's why there were so
many of them of uh parts of the Gan is
Jack right okay I don't know any pop
culture so when you question me I
immediately lose confidence I don't
understand what words you said it sound
like K Riv it's how he said camder I
don't know what I was like I'll start
again jack SP the depiction of Captain
Jack Sparrow is so iconic people loved
him that's why there were so many of
them to say not only do you not get
original content because we don't
actually really care about giving you
something fresh as an actor to work work
with we're also going to set you up to
be directly compared to a character
people loved always I mean that's like
setting someone up to fail I feel like
not only do they not get the chance to
perform sort of authentically with their
own talents and skills they also just
live in the shadow of this white guy
forever so uh who's that guy Kum njami
or whatever his name is yeah it's Kum
njami Kum n he apparently like had to
get therapy because his his movie his
Marvel movie bombed oh did you guys see
this W seriously
yeah I think scan nothing wrong with
therapy I guess I don't sure but it was
like his movie did so poorly and I just
find it funny because this Dei stuff
getting called out Disney Elon Musk
suing SNL is literally asking a white
man who is being who's been attacked
relentlessly by the left for being like
you know anti-asian or homophobic or
whatever they're just like we don't care
we're going to we're going to totally
bring them on I'm just like the writings
on the wall for these corporations they
know they're losing money by doing all
this woke stuff and I think it's only a
matter of time the movies all fall line
the fact that that Kum guy had to get
therapy you think they're going to
consider him for another lead role in
one of these movies look at the Marvels
the worst grossing Marvel movie ever
worse than the Hulk which like nobody
even considers to be part of it even
though it is is that not counting
inflation just pure numbers just gross
terribly or is that only been like 10
years so I don't think inflation is
playing a big role in those numbers
right now though to be honest
considering the past four years maybe my
initial thought was the Dei is just I
mean the the curtain's been pulled back
it it's so disgusting to force certain
races into positions of power just
because of their skin color but they're
not even positions of power like at a
corporation we're going to hire you for
that role considering that role a
position of power you got the job that's
the power but don't they do that anyways
they have di Dei hirings even if it's
just a random Corporation being like
it's not it's not a position of power so
uh for instance I've actually
experienced this you know having worked
in an office with a bunch of women I
have worked with very capable women who
are substantially better than half the
guys there was one uh producer that I
worked with at Vice and later at Fusion
who was like literally one of the best
and they treated her like crap and when
her documentaries actually won awards
she wasn't invited and I'm like see
that's a good example of them just being
like so it happens however that being
said there were also women who were
hired just because they needed women and
then at meetings you'd get like do we
have any ideas for for pitches and the
guys would say something like here's ins
insert mediocre idea another guy would
say here here's insert slightly good
idea and then the woman would go here's
insert the worst idea imaginable here's
woman idea and then everyone would be
like yeah we're not interested in that
and then later she'd be like they won't
listen to my ideas because I'm a woman
and I'm like I got I gotta be honest
like that was bad like there's there's
Amy award-winning journalists here who
are women like it's not because you're
woman it's because you're bad at this
and the problem is when they do these
quotas it is not the best person for the
job like Mark cubin is purely wrong
about this yeah I think and that it's
becoming obvious to people like it's
similar to The Border crisis it's very
obvious to most people that and and it
seems obvious to the producers at SNL
they're like yo this our cast has been
floundering like the show I've only seen
Clips over the last three or four years
but it's been bad it's been really
really bad and Shane can come in there
and show those guys how to act like even
if it's just for one night they're
hanging out for a whole week he's one of
the funniest comedians on earth like
he's got a Vibe that's like chill but
aggressive I think it's really good for
the show to have him there MH yeah I
mean have him back the thing is it's for
business they're doing this because they
want the show to be profitable and that
is what concerns me that business is
more powerful oh it shouldn't concern
you it's good if they want if they have
him back because they're like hey this
is much better for us that's great
because they're doing with bu light
they're saying hey the writing is on the
wall like Tim said that we don't want to
do this woke thing anymore because all
it does is we go broke we lose money we
go we go broke like that's what we've
been saying for a long time I think it's
a good thing I I think we have to
reflect on the fact that they they fired
him I they could have had him there
balancing out the cast from the
beginning and instead they were like
you're too risky we don't want you here
and now they pay the price for it right
literally day one yeah which is crazy
which I mean if they it's almost like
recognizing that they maybe could have I
I don't watch SNL so I don't really know
you know what what they could have done
but theoretically if you had this other
voice is other perspective on Comedy you
would have balanced out your writing in
a way that maybe would have kept you
more culturally relevant I think so
although arguably yeah I think you're
right for sure Shane being there would
have been a good influence on the comedy
and they had the option they they chose
to say no you're too bold risky we don't
want to be on The Cutting Edge and then
they sent themselves back right they
they aren't that interesting anymore
yeah the downside could have been that
SNL clammed him up and kept him on but
kept them quiet and not funny because
they didn't want to piss off the wrong
people yeah I think this whole thing in
being quote unquote cancelled was like
like I said earlier like it kind of made
his career and he's definitely realized
that and I think if he if like like you
said he would have been like kind of uh
you know hemmed up from actually being
as funny as he really is and being able
to explore what he's
I would also argue that the the career
path for standup comedians is really
broadened with the Advent podcasting
YouTube and the internet and things like
that like when if you if you listen to
like you know Tina Fay talk about it she
doing improv being part of these big
groups launched you into Hollywood
launched you to movies whatever else
they didn't have the same outlets and so
in some ways Maybe by not having to
immediately get on that machine he was
able to develop more in in more
authentically as a comedian because he
had to say like well this is what I'm
going to do and this is how I'm going to
continue to hone my craft as a standup
comedian it used to be Upright Citizens
Brigade in Chicago or it was like an
improv groups and then those people
would kind of fast track up to the SNL
thing but now like Rogan dude shout out
to Joe Rogan for putting Shane Gillis on
the map because when Shane got fired it
was like he probably thought his life
was over and then Joe was like well
actually you're one of the coolest guys
I know come on my show over and over and
now they're like best friends like in a
group of really good friends so nice job
Joe he he knows Talent when he sees it
Shane so awesome dude I mean it looks
like they're getting you know in the
last week 4.5 million viewers is that up
or
down I mean it's it's literally down
from like a long time ago but I think
they're actually doing moderately well
right now SNL they're like steady I
don't know it's hard it's hard to find
the exact numbers to be complely honest
but it is regardless yeah I wonder how
many of those numbers how many of those
people watch it live anymore 11:30 on
Saturday there's so many other things
4.5 million but there's so many other
things you could be doing on a Saturday
night than watching TV I don't believe
it I literally do not believe it when we
have like on on the internet you have
hard numbers right away and even those
are somewhat hard to track because you
still get bot traffic and things like
this but then you get like neelon
ratings where they're like we estimate
based on some boxes oh it's you know
it's like it's like the Family Guy joke
where the TV executive gets a phone call
and he's like we just got 10 complaints
that means 14 billion people are mad
yeah you know that's how it works so
they're like oh 5 million people
watching I'm like I don't buy it cuz I
honestly don't know anybody who could
name a cast member of SNL and I know
people are going to say like doesn't
that mean you're not going outside bro I
go hang out National Harbor I go hang
out these at these at these places with
regular people all the time and these
things are just like I have no
idea could could you guys name a single
cast member right now on SNL I mean oh
Keenan Keenan wait Keenan still on the
show yeah what's his real name uh I
don't know his real name but I would I
was going to say Michael like Michael
Shay and what's his name calling you Jo
like those guys that's it yeah they're
like one of them's married to Scarlett
Johansson that's what I know oh okay
look I know pop culture I'm aware Pete's
off the show Pete I know his first name
he had tattoos Pete Davidson he's not on
anymore though but didn't he only just
play himself over and over again yeah
kind of sometimes he's kind of he's
funny um the who's that girl that that
one girl too no I guess the answer is no
we're not do a great job that one girl
and that guy who's married to her like
it's rough I mean I don't Michael Shay
Colin
Jo uh who else is there Keenan Thompson
oh yeah right yeah Keenan name all the
men he been on Long wom yeah who are the
girls that are on irrelevant to us
apparently apparently I don't know I
have this list and I'm like the show was
Bowen Bowen Yang okay it's like it's a
lot to live Walker Chloe tro never heard
of I know Keenan Thompson he's like he's
an OG he's been since all that you know
what I mean Sarah sh I have no idea who
these people are this all of them
forever yeah ego NM no idea who that is
um Michael
Longfellow Molly Kerney oh I've heard of
m Molly Cy I've heard of her Punky
Johnson funny name James Austin Johnson
I don't know um Marcelo
Hernandez Heidi
Gardner khloee Fineman that one sounds
kind of familiar Andrew dismukes Mikey
day Michael Shay we know that Michael
Shay got viral Clips maybe because I
don't know with the internet like comedy
is more real and so this corporate
comedy is like obviously corporate they
can't say on SNL but I can say it
on YouTube you know and it's actually
enjoyable on on this venue but like on
that there's still like Bound by these
weird yeah and it it's just not the only
place you have to go anymore so maybe
people who would have auditioned for it
and tried to get in they think ah I'm
too edgy they won't take me anyway so I
won't go and I'll I'll start my own
thing over there I mean in some ways
it's it's good right because it gives
other people options to start YouTube
channel start podcast do more live
presentations uh I think that again I I
feel like I can't totally critique it
because I don't watch SNL regularly but
I just think that we have moved away
from cable TV as a culture and this is
not cable TV what is it this is free
terrestrial Network NBC television even
then like I feel like people have just
moved away from it they moved away from
like uh programming like um what do you
call it scheduled programming yeah it's
everything people if you want to listen
to something you listen to it on demand
and so there's not the same level I mean
I guess this is live so that sort of
brings an element to it that maybe you'd
want to watch but I don't know it just
doesn't seem as attractive as a form of
entertainment anymore yeah man I used to
watch it in the 90s with uh Wayne's
World I mean that's where Mike Myers and
Dana Carvey started Wayne's World was a
was a I was going to say a YouTube skit
it was an SNL skit thanks YouTube for
building yourself shout out to Chad
hurle and all the guys making this
website what a what a groundbreaking
technology this was yeah it was re
revolutionary we got Ryan long we got
all these awesome comedians doing their
own thing but they don't have a TV show
like Theo Von and and you know Brian Ken
and Joe Rogan if they had a show like
SNL that'd be pretty badass I want to
talk about this story we actually
overlooked it it's from a week ago but
it's about something we talked about and
I think we just never it never fit into
the schedule the boys star Aaron morard
quits Instagram after Megan Kelly's
plastic surgery claims okay first it
wasn't Megan Kelly's claims Megan Kelly
was picking up on a meme that everybody
else was talking about and it's actually
got its own Know Your Meme page but the
meme was someone posted this picture of
Aon morard she's an actress she's on the
show the boys and they said women need
to stop getting plastic surgery and they
showed this image of Aaron morard she
does she she absolutely looks like she
got tons of plas I gotta be honest do
you guys remember when um the weekend
did that bit where he put the bandages
on his face was he like the Grammys or
something and then when savior tears
music video came out his face was all
goofy looking and everybody thought he
got plastic surgery but it was just a a
joke like her face looks like that I'm
not trying to be mean but it looks like
yo what did you do here's the crazy
thing she she I don't think she
explicitly said I never got plastic
surgery she said it was like it was
false don't say that actually oh yeah we
have the Know Your Meme page where they
uh they talk about I wonder if they have
I think they'll have the original uh
viral photo it was this one right here
Royce Lopez said women need to stop
plastic surgery until we figure out
what's wrong why would you ruin your
face like this this is Aaron morti from
the boys she was already very pretty
what she responded with because this is
where it started she went after Megan
Kelly I guess Megan Kelly had a had the
platform that she's thought a Target but
uh a lot of big shows a lot of following
we're talking about it and she was like
that photo from when I was like underage
and I'm very young and this photo is
like new and she's like they're all
false but she clearly looks very
different she claimed it was just like
makeup but everyone's kind of going
after her over it cuz there's a photo
here and I think this one's more recent
here's what here's here's what matters
she ends up deleting her entire
Instagram and I don't know if she got
plastic surgery or not it certainly
looks like she does and many people are
saying yo you did here's what matters
though youo she thought she looked good
she thought this like right here can we
pull that
up she thought that looked good and so
the question is what is happening
with social media that there are women
who are like I want to look like this
and
then I guess inversely or subsequently
you get such a backlash to people saying
you look gross that she deleted her
Instagram out right she didn't delete
like she she deleted all the photos and
then put up a thing being like screw you
Megan Kelly I kind of feel like you know
I don't want to be dick to her I don't
know or anything like that but we've got
this filter crisis and this Instagram
image crisis for young women but this is
actually as bad as it is a promising
sign moving forward that these filters
and the surgery is resulting in a
negative backlash and they're starting
to realize like don't do this to
yourself you know what I mean yeah like
labotomy they I I don't know it's aot
not saying it's like a labot but they
went through the really thin eyebrows
that were really popular in the '90s
like no don't do that they had to learn
how horrible the labotomy was to stop
doing it to themselves is what I was
saying same with plastic surgery I am so
adamantly opposed to whether it's
plastic surgery fillers even Botox to
some extent because I think young women
are being told we were talking about
this before the show I think it's some
sort of derivation of of refinement
culture in the sense that you think just
because your lips are are bigger or
whatever you get done if your eyes mic
your eyebrows microbladed or whatever
like you will look better but it's not I
think once you enter that realm it's
like that picture frankly to me again no
disrespect but she looks like an alien
like she doesn't look look human whether
it's the buckle fat removal or whatever
she's doing and I think you're very
correct in terms of like the
psychological harm to young women with
the filters and you see stuff online and
you're like what I don't look like that
and there's that side of the issue but I
also think too that you have been seeing
although you guys probably know CU
you're not young women but maybe you you
share the same sentiment like they are
really really really pushing Botox and
fillers at a much younger age now like I
always talk about my mom with this like
it seems like now the age that they're
trying to Prime you to say that Botox
you need to it is like 22 23 where it
used to be in like that's the that's the
new thing like Kylie Jenner yeah because
of that and I think in some ways the
critique of that is like the big Pharma
right like this big Beauty right wants
people to be buying into the system I
figured it out and because you have to
maintain it I know what's going
on it's intentionally being done by
these big tech companies to convince
women to start looking more and more
plastic and fake so that way when the
Androids start integrating in society
will know the difference no I honestly
thought for a while it was because it's
trying to make everyone's face look more
the same because if you get surger like
I think I references tweet went but
there were some girl like I ask my
surgeon if if the botox I got my face is
going to make me how many years it's
going to take off me he's like no you'll
just look the same as everyone else with
botox who's your age and these things
can tend to come in Trends right so like
right now they were all getting the the
fat taken out of their mouths which
makes the cheekbones more prominent or
you know maybe they'll all want eyebrow
lifts so they're all do their eye like
some of it is makeup you know the same
way but then when you're doing this face
technology it's because all the faces
are averaging out to be the same thing
but not in a good way so I love this uh
this Trope about like old people pulling
their pants up really high we used to
have this in like the '90s the TV shows
would always make fun of old people
there was one where like I can't
remember what cartoon it is but it's
like the character gets turned into an
old man and as soon as he does his pants
go straight up to his armpits that's not
because old people do it it's because a
generation did it and so the younger
generation did not do it the idea that
it was because you were old was just
because people saw old people doing that
at the time right now we don't have a
generation of elderly plastic surgery up
tattooed plastic people it is going to
be wild when we do could you imagine in
like 40 years what these people are
going to look like what the Buckle fat
that you're taking out is
going I was being serious with Kylie
Jenner they're like their cheeks are
going to rot open like there's nothing
in there anymore and I mean this girl I
Mor did say you know when I was younger
my face looks slightly different that's
fair everyone's face changes a little
bit the age but all of the women who get
BOTOX or anything else that stuff has to
be maintained or it shifts I mean you
see this over and over again with
celebrities who have had bad work done
or just work done really early they have
to continue to go under the knife or
under the needle I guess to get it
maintained which means to your point
they're always paying for it they are
consistently a customer let on the fact
that like some of the augmentations that
you can get done can cause you you know
different issues your body can reject
you know breast implants or whatever
they're making it so so you are
medically dependent for a long time
because you're always trying to look
younger and the fads that change are all
the fads always change so you're
constantly trying to adjust your face to
fit in with the youngest generation I
think it's the irony or I guess Paradox
of of feminism because I'm sure they say
oh I can do whatever I want with my face
me I wear makeup for myself right I'm
getting my Buckle fat removed for myself
but it's not you're seeking validation
from other people but the prime
beneficiary and people who profit off of
that usually would' be slamming big
Pharma but it's it's the big beauty
industry and I don't know if you saw
that Trend about like the young girls
who like eight years old going into
Sephora that's crazy that 8-year-olds
are wearing so much makeup and I have to
say this is a hot take I am I'm just I
am so anti plastic surgery having grown
up in Los Angeles I have seen so many
young girls to the point I'm like I
don't even think it's legal to operate
on you get work done where it's like you
don't need it you're the most beautiful
you'll ever be you're perfect but I
think it's sort of like transgender
inspired I know that's a weird thing to
say but I I I think if you look at some
of the surgeries and the stuff that
they're getting done it is the same
thing make masculine and feminist faces
look more similar it's the same stuff
that male to female transgender people
get and oh wow yeah it makes like if you
make it so all the women's faces look
the same and they look actually like
they have some masculine Tendencies
you're normalizing people who are like
I'm actually going to live this way you
know it makes femininity easier to
achieve when the concept of being a
feminine woman is like you know the
bimbo look of huge lips
hug brows big cheeks because then guys
eyelashes all of this stuff the other
part is that that women just like people
come out and say I regret you know
genital alteration surgeries there are
people who come out and say I regret
having worked into my face this was
Bella Hadid somewhat recently who said
you know I had this nose job I think
when she was like 16 pretty young and
she said the nose that I had was
reflective of my culture and ancestry
and I wish that I hadn't have changed it
I mean the things that women are doing
to feel like they are achieving the
Instagram level of beauty is so
disconnected from reality that if they
unplug from it I think that they
wouldn't hate themselves so much I mean
it looks like she got lip fillers
doesn't it she got lip fillers it looks
like the shape of her lip change she got
her brows I think microbladed done nose
job definitely nose job I do think you
know a lot of women their FA is like fat
but it's too dram filler is a huge thing
she said all these videos are false but
never explicitly said I never got
surgery and so a lot of people responded
being like stop lying big but there are
like videos from plastic surgeons
surgeons being like dude she didn't get
surgery it's like she was saying that
she got her Contours done or whatever
what is that like makeup yeah like she
has something emphasizing her cheekbones
that is true you can see it on her face
but I think it's enough where I would
think that she has some kind of implant
or something she used to not have a
jawline before now she has a jaw yeah
she had a much more round face and it's
not enough to be like oh well I just
grew up I lost the baby fat like it's
it's more dramatic fake hair to I would
also argue that like she looks like
she's had a brow lift because like the
hooding on her eyes seems different to
me in a way that's not just like oh I I
got older my face changed like it's too
dramatic it's wild that she took this
photo of herself and she was like I look
good and then she posted look like an
alien but everyone around her told her
she looked good the woman who did her
makeup the woman who did her hair
they're like no she paid to do her
makeup right and who get exposure if
she's T they're tagged in her Instagram
post and other are like well how do I
look like her they got exposure who's
going to hire this makeup artist now
there's three things transgender people
three things that um are make women
attractive to men I was told lately is
symmetry um the hip to waist ratio and
the um the illusion of health so it's
not necessarily that they're healthy
it's that they seem healthy to the man
and if they're watching the Tucker Putin
interview well that's the hottest um
that goes without you're you're at a bar
and she's on her phone and you look over
and she's watching Tucker Carlson
interview Vladimir Putin you're like or
she's watching Tim Tim cat yeah that's
um so they're going for symmetry with
this plastic surgery they want to but it
does not seem healthy that's the problem
with plastic surgery is it doesn't give
off the illusion of Health it gives off
the illusion of I've got botulism in my
face or I've got scar I've got some
weird chemicals under my skin I saw this
uh this a really funny meme and it's
like woman and she's looking at a
shampoo bottle and it says shampoo for
dry and damaged hair and then it's like
man and it's like sixin one men's hair
armpit knees skin cloth carpet engine
cleaner MH it's like that's about right
yeah I I go to the hotels and it's like
shampoo and body wash and I'm like what
you're like okay I just hate when these
people I'm pretty sure it's the same
thing I think they're lying to everybody
and they say like I'm doing it for
myself it's empowering to me it's like
just cut the crap and then I'm sure like
these women are doing it for other women
of course I I do think there is an
interesting she's not complained about
the guys who said it she's complaining
about Megan Kelly but like I feel like
women perceive what when women think
what is attractive they're looking at it
from a very female perspective in other
words like what girls consider
attractive as different from guys and I
think in some ways I don't think that
that that is attractive at all but like
what women have been told is attractive
coming from guess it big Beauty I don't
know what the right term would be but is
that look like that is that is an on
Trend look it's on Trend I think that's
the perfect way to put put it which is
like women are looking to see if you're
on Trend if you're doing the current
things right whereas men because a lot
of it is biological the things that they
find attractive or desirable kind of
stay the same
but beauty industry standards and Trends
change all the time so women are looking
to see if you are like fashionable
whereas men are looking to see if you're
attractive and I you know do whatever
you want to do if you want to look
attracted for men if you want to look
trendy for women it doesn't matter to me
you just have to acknowledge I think
this is the problem with you know she
got upset with Megan Kelly because women
are not supposed to attack or be mean to
other women but I think true friendship
would be able to say like hey I don't
think that's the best look for you I
don't know that you need to go get all
of these fillers I think you're okay the
Way You Are may maybe women women
friendship man friendship would be like
oh what did you do to your face bro
she's she's doing more harm to young
women by passing that off is natural and
acting like people have noses like that
and your brows could be that full and
your hair could look like that and
you're like or that Growing Up 3 to four
years you're going to look that
different that is a much more harmful
narrative than women pointing out hey
you made some really dumb decisions you
messed up your again we weren't saying
she was ugly to begin with I think the
real tragedy in the story is that she's
was a very beautiful girl yeah but her
argument is she didn't get surgery
you're just calling her
old what's wrong with being old like
this is no no no this is the point she
said that's how people age she did not
get surgery she got makeup done and
everyone's posting a picture of her when
she was young saying she was beautiful
and then a picture of when she's old
saying she's ugly like it's not just
this one photo it's the uh there's uh
where do they have it this this uh this
photo here on the left where where's
here we go this one wheels on a shopping
cart be like and it's her when she's
like 17 and then her when she's like 30
and this is what she's saying she's like
I didn't get surgery you're just posting
pictures of me now being like you're
ugly so it's like she got old and now
they're calling her ugly oh wow I wonder
if she is has an eating disorder and
it's just a lot of makeup I mean her
cheeks are sunken in right here and it
makes her cheekbones stick out much more
than when she was like younger or
whatever she has a very round face I
also feel like that Buckle fat look
first of all it's like so on Trend with
all of that that Hollywood crowd and
that's just not a very natural like
physiognomy thing I think for a pretty
round face American person to have maybe
if you're like Native American and you
have super high cheekbones if you're
like Eastern European or something but I
just I don't buy it what about makeup
you guys think like cuz I've always
found like yeah I think it's unnecessary
I feel like it clouds the the woman like
it kind of agree
1,000% and I think part of the critique
is that a lot of the times I really
don't think you look better like I said
I think it is refinement culture to some
extent like yeah your lips will be a
different shade but different isn't
always better and I think too I think a
lot of these this is what I've sort of
learned you know the toxic chemicals and
the endocrine disruptors and all the
phalates and all these products aside
like it really is just an industry that
prays on the vulnerabilities and
insecurities of of women and that's
that's why I think the real irony and
how you see it really be weaponized that
that prevailing narrative right that
women do makeup for themselves which is
BS it's not true but the corporations
need that narrative because that helps
their bottom line I think that's why
they Blended right now the big movement
is to have it be like skincare makeup
right like all of the things you can
have are actually skincare and so it's
not makeup and whatever else when when
actually women have worn makeup for
hundreds of years like if you want to
that's fine but I don't think that
you're ever going to be able to wear
enough makeup to fund fundamentally
change your face if your face has
fundamentally changed you have probably
turned to some kind of intervention
remember when Jordan Peterson talked
about why women wear makeup mhm yeah
it's to enhance it's to make the the
woman look like she's fertile like the
lips yeah the lips puff out they become
more red blood rushes to the lips so
they're simulating that yep I think it's
transhumanist I think a lot of this
stuff is part of a transhumanist started
several thousand years ago when women
were rubbing berries on their lips for
sure that was the beginning of
transhumanism there really is a though
and not to get too in the weeds with
with makeup you guys don't strike me as
the the makeup tutorial type but like
there's a difference between I think
putting on like darker lipstick and like
lining your lips and mascara that is
like enhancing your natural beauty but
what you really saw with the Kardashians
and the shift in this was this concept
of contouring which is literally adding
different shades and hollowing out parts
of your face to change not enhance but
to entirely change your face and when
you see those crazy YouTube tutorials of
like the different shades of colors the
shades of brown around the eyes the all
again I'm wearing makeup I'm happy to
admit that there some that say like I
remember there's a Toral it's like how
to look like you had a nose job without
actually getting nose job and it's like
her really intensely using all kinds of
Shades to change her nose and at a
certain point you want to be like what
are you going to do when you have to
take that off the eye thing too yeah
where the women have like put they they
put white slightly around their eye to
make their eyes look bigger m czy is
this all like uh the Kardashians was
that late '90s early 2000s 2000s cuz
that's when started to change in the '
80s it was way too much makeup big
hairspray then in the '90s it's people
started to get more real like women
started to look normal and then Shi like
exploded in the early 2000s think that
the like trans Community I'm not saying
it's like the individual trans but
whatever the agenda like those nefarious
forces I think they loved they love the
commodification of Womanhood and
femininity as you know orange foundation
with really hollowed
out but I'm I'm saying what you're
seeing and the way women's makeup is
going I think it is going like a drag
route in some ways right absolutely well
and and the rise of U the Kardashians I
to me it coincides with the rise of male
YouTube makeup artists getting really
popular who would do these really strong
Contours who would have these really
block brows and that look is somewhere
between the Kardashians and drag and it
sort of stayed that way and became
trendy among young girls what I love is
if you're a male YouTube makeup guy you
probably are more likely to get
you're more likely to get sponsored by a
Makeup Company because makeup companies
had 50% of the potential market share CU
only women do it and so their mentality
is if we convince men to wear makeup we
will double our market share and so and
you get a bunch of male influencers you
go into Sephora now and there used to
never really be pictures of men now you
go around and it's not just men it's
like we're going to go to super chats
cuz we're we're going so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.net live events in Martinsburg
West Virginia once a month and then
maybe if we feel like we might do more
than that who knows depending on uh
depends on how successful they are but
we will read your super chats for now so
smash that like button let's go Tim Jake
says your broadcast is up early today
sometimes just depends on if we know
what the story is and it's easy to do so
we're up here before doing
pre-production choosing story selection
what's the top story and things like
this and uh this one's obvious Tucker
Carlson news was huge the EU sanctions
and then of course were waiting for that
interview to drop and then you had these
viral tweets to the tune of like 5 to 10
million hits on Twitter claiming he was
on this hit list so he definitely wanted
to address
that Daniel uh kmian Tucker planned on
interviewing Putin when he was with Fox
until his team discovered the NSA was
spying on them they were reading his
texts and emails yeah I think I heard
that that was like a big deal barely a
Millennials says Trump V Anderson case
on scotus docket tomorrow how do you see
that going also if you've watch 24 you
should could never be made today
Anderson that's the um that's that's the
uh ballot case let me check before I say
anything I believe that's the ballot
access one right I think so he's got so
many cases that sometimes when it's the
specific name yes uh related to the 14th
Amendment of the United States yeah I
think Trump has declined to appear but
this will be interesting to say the
least um should be really really
interesting I mean what if scota says no
he's out
that's why Matt Gates and Lisa phonic
were like we're going to have this
resolution saying he did not
Insurrection you know what I mean yeah
it's definitely strategic I I think it's
unlikely that they say he's out but I I
just don't trust anything it's hard to
make a prediction they're going to say
convict him they're going to say if he's
not been convicted you can't remove him
it could be interesting though they may
come back and say elections are to be
held in accordance with the state
legislators legislator's approval as per
the Constitution period have a nice day
the Democrats are going to say that of
course because all the Democratic
justices care about is whether or not
they they gain power for their for their
cult the conservatives are going to be
like we are honorable and and have
integrity and the Constitution says the
states are in charge that's it they're
going to say if you run your election
the way you want to run it we got no we
got no issue in that case Maine pulls
him off the pulls him off the belly
instantly Trump could with RFK Jr in the
race Trump could win Maine that's the
craziest thing not that he would but you
know if RFK Jr pulls enough away
let's go Keith says super packs have to
go yeah not a big fan but there's a
challenge you can spend your money
however you see fit I was arguing with
these dudes uh in like 2012 outside of
CPAC I was should say argu I was talking
and like Dan lash is outside and
everyone's like all gawking at her all
these leftists were like look who it is
it's her she's evil and uh I was like I
don't like the idea of all this
unlimited spending in politics because
it just means the wealthy have instant
access that regular working people don't
and then they were and then some guy
said to me he was like you have money on
you and I was like yeah and he was like
okay you can't spend it on these
products I said so and I'm like we do
that all the time we like kids can't buy
beer you can't buy you know uh uh
certain Contraband things we could
certainly say you can't spend money on
politics his argument was I should I
earned the money I worked hard I should
have a right to spend it on whatever I
want and if I want to buy a billboard
saying vote for somebody that's my free
speech and I was like sure but we do as
a government say some things can't be
bought you can't go to a grocery store
and buy hair in so there are some things
you cannot spend your money on and that
was the gist of the argument I do
understand that argument I do I I agree
with the concept if I want to buy a
billboard why ises anyone allowed to
stop me it's my free speech that's a
pack political action committee says we
want to do it how do you tell them they
can't spend their money on what they
want to
say so there's rules not that anyone
follows them Christina paaon says shout
out Mason de Champs AKA pro-life
Spider-Man he free climbed the sphere in
Las Vegas today let's get him on IRL
really well I will say you know a lot of
people a lot of people a lot of the
publicists who hit us up don't
understand what IRL is this is a topical
news commentary show not an interview
program that's why we launched the
culture War which you can find over at
tenet media on YouTube that's the
interview show yo Mason is awesome I met
him at turning point we got to have him
out here someday I mean yeah he's great
he's just a great human it's entirely
Poss is capable of handling a news
commentary show like if you want to know
about someone's life story cult War fits
better yeah he'd be great talk about
climbing like he climbs buildings it's
crazy with his bare
hands let's get
it Sterling Wilson II third says don't
worry Ian we've all been there with loud
eating and drinking LOL thanks I'll
never forget tonight oh yeah Eloy Lopez
curio says thank you thank you so much
for reading my last comment yesterday
about my books I literally screamed in
my car I watch y'all every single day
blessings Amigos right on well
congratulations good luck happy to
hear Justin SLA says Daria dugina is
marked as liquidated on that list yeah a
lot of people are pointing out the list
that Tucker Carlson is on has a bunch of
people and they're described as
liquidated when they die so you know and
she was assassinated so you know Yep
they're just they're just keeping track
of what's going on they don't have
anything to do with
it all
right the sigp says Gonzalo lra died in
Ukraine but it's not a kill list that's
exactly why I said it's half wrong half
true it's not a literal kill list it's a
list of it's an enemies list and we know
what happens to people who are listed as
enemies so it's like and but but more
more to the point it was half year
because he wasn't just added to to a
list he's been on it for months so
everyone's like he was added to this
list because it was Interview with Putin
he was in there he was on it in August
you know what I mean like they they've
not liked this guy for a long time so
certainly Man Tucker better be careful
need some good security you know what I
mean all right Wyatt cinberg says 24
reminds me of 68 n peaked and people
were talking World War II the right and
left were talking civil war LBJ was so
unpopular he wouldn't seek a second term
King and RFK were feared by the Deep
State and
shot yikes that's why you want to
remember history so you're not doomed to
repeat it yeah gamer J says if the
Border Protection Bill included an
allowance of 5,000 Russians into Ukraine
daily and 5,000 Palestinians into Israel
per day they would all vote against it
including the media they're all
corrupted yeah Alx had that tweet say
saying propose a bill that allows 5,000
Russians into Ukraine every day and see
what they say MH yeah they'd be like no
and house Democrats are also vote I mean
they're voting down Standalone vills
they want all of the aid and everything
lumped together I don't understand this
like if this is something that's so
urgent we these countries desperately
need funding why wouldn't you compromise
and vote on a standard loone Bill
instead it's like no everything has to
be Lum together and we so we can sneak
these weird Provisions in the the the
the difficult thing is they tried to do
a standalone Israel Aid package but
fiscal Republicans were like no way
we're not funding Israel but the
strategy there was to force the
Democrats to reject
it and I guess they sort of they sort of
got that cuz it was voted down and it
was it was only 14 Republicans but
that's kind of the idea
now Democrats are going to have to uh
explain to most people why they're
choosing the path they're choosing and
opposing Israel I just don't think they
could say anything that would make sense
but I maybe I'm just optimistic on their
voter base the October 7th thing the
October 7th Terror attacks and mass
killings really caused problems for the
establishment and the woke
like blm's posting the paraglider this
is the point the Republicans are trying
to make force the Democrats into a
position they can't win yeah I think
that people think the Deep state is like
an American thing but it's like bigger
than this country C AA says headlines
when Tucker interviews Putin Putin
propagandist deserves to be imprisoned
as a traitor to democracy headlines when
BBC interviews Putin heroic journalist
gives us closed curtain view of the
raving authoritarian madman bent on
democracy's destruction yep
I love this there's like this BBC guy
and he's like Tucker Carlson says we've
not even tried to interview him of
course we tried he just won't let us
like it's not surprising dude you work
for the British government you are at
war with Russia of course he won't Grant
you an interview Tucker Carlson's a
private citizen who is considered
opposition media in this country of
course he'll get an interview these
people are so dumb why do you think it
is these leftists don't come on this
show we invite them every single time
because they view us as enemies and they
know that we will debunk all their lives
that's it they're full of it handful of
them will come on the honest ones but
that's about it honest but wrong perhaps
not wrong on everything I I am happy to
say that when uh Destiny and I were
talking about you know uh gender
ideology and things like that I had many
facts that were wrong and we corrected
them on the air and had our discussion
to determine what we thought was right
and wrong and I I respect Destiny though
I think he's wrong um I think we agree a
lot on facts but I think he has bad
moral opinions that's that's really what
it comes down to the rest of the left
they just make things up and then claim
other people make things up my favorite
thing was uh you know I gave that shout
out to Taylor Loren when she was like
Tim pool's not a journalist he only
comments on other people's stuff and
he's dishonest so I'm kind of like okay
if I'm only referencing other people's
journalism you're saying these
journalists are putting out fake news
I'm being dishonest by reporting on what
they've said is basically her point I'll
take it I guess but I will stress I host
an interview show once a week that's
journalist
otherwise Christian Amor is not a
journalist I'd like to have Taylor Loren
in for the culture War that'd be cool
well she would not do it because she
would get
obliterated like everything she says I'd
be like here's the New York Times saying
you're wrong what say you and she'd be
like you're being dishonest I'm like I
guess the New York Times is wrong okay
next subject here's NPR saying you're
wrong I mean let let me do this what do
you think Taylor Len would say if you
went to her and said there are serious
concerns that China was taking people's
DNA through covid tests to create a DNA
database what do you think she'd say
that's crazy that's a conspiracy NPR
reported that it's my favorite story
it's like NPR reported this that's the
source Google it NPR reported fears that
China could be collecting DNA through
covid tests bgi genomics is that the
company there you go see bgi
genomics but you know she's going to be
like that's not true that's a
cons think anything she you would
present as from you she would disagree
with on his face because there's but
none of it's for me like she said right
but you wouldn't lead with NPR said this
so she'd be like oh Tim everything
you're saying is crazy right right and
then when she said that's crazy I'd say
oh you think that's fake okay here's NPR
that's where I got the news Well NPR
must have brought this up to dissuade
like I just think that there's a level
of not wanting to have a conversation
with
anyone like when Taylor Loren doxed Libs
of Tik Tok it was UN questionable doxing
literally posting an address and then
claiming but that's not her current real
address and it's just like an address
she wants used so it's like dude no one
is arguing the depth of doxing no one is
arguing it's third degree doxing versus
sth degree doxing we're saying you
posted an address which very well could
have been hers at the time and in fact
was hers and she had fled from it so
it's like but I didn't doct her CU she
wasn't there oh shut up that's so stupid
and then she got mad Apparently after we
put up that bill board I teamed up with
the daily wire guys put a billboard in
Time Square that said Taylor Len's docs
livs of Tik Tok hilarious apparently I
hear behind the scenes she was like
fuming and demanding like legal action
and they told her they couldn't do
anything it's a protected opinion like
Define doxing and here's the funny thing
if I was wrong about that as a statement
of fact yeah she could have sued but the
reality is they they probably told her
look if you sue him he's going to show
the news article saying you did this and
then a judge will B the G saying you did
this and then how are you going to deny
it she can deny it right now until a
court says
so all right saddle effing says
Tucker interviewing Putin is the inverse
of Jane Fonda in Vietnam this is the
highest treason to The Establishment
searching for Truth for the
truth crazy
days Garrett Russell says am I watching
days of my life or CNN in reference to
the zalinsky interview we saying we
needed like a long lost twin brother to
appear and be like you've stolen the
presidency from me brother what I
thought I trapped you in the ice caves
in Antarctica you know what I mean then
like that' be so great we never found
out what his favorite band was that's
what I was waiting for I still want to
know I'm I'm going to watch the video
after this I need to know it's going to
be like what's a what's a what's a Bad
Company no it's got to be like a band
that is famous but kind of
like you know
like earthwind and fire no they're great
how dare you how dare you you don't
think would just pick like The Beetles
to seem relatable every he think he'd go
a little bit lower on the list it's got
to be a classic rock band that's famous
Birds but like when you say you go oh
you know what I mean like uh like you
can't name earthwind and fire that's a
that's that little more famous Cardinal
I'm going to go with the Yard Birds no
no no earthwind and fire they're great
when you say Earth to fire people are
like wow they're fantastic so ly's got
to name a band where you go really you
know mean like I guess
Turtles like they have a good song I
guess they have a good song but like
does anybody really care yeah and he's
like just naming albums like really that
that could be it yeah the turtles like
they had one big song and they had a
couple little ones can you name any
songs by The Turtles besides for besides
happy together no not off the top of my
head not anybody chat I don't even know
who the turtles are to be hon happy
together I don't know what are
talking for yeah I know that one right
you didn't even know the band see that's
a good point he'd say the turtles You'
go who he's going to say something
that's really hits home with a lot of
people so famous band really well- loved
zeppel if what if he said Taylor Swift
that'd be hot but he is saying it is
being quoted as band everywhere so that
makes me think that is in fact a band is
he going to say you is you a band or
just a person yeah but they're not
classic rock I I can only find the video
I can't you isn't classic rock what if
he was like Ace of Bas I was just
listening to them yeah uh I live I
watched them today I was watching Ace of
Bas and singing it in the house that's
wild yeah um all that she wants is
another baby she's gone tomorrow boy all
that she wants is anotherab great said
that i' be like oh it's kind of obscure
The Cardigans that's a good band yeah
they're good I like The Cardigans my
favorite classic rock that's all he said
I guess well I think of the 70s when I
think classic rock anything in the ' 80s
is more modern rock hence if he said
Tears for Fears I get angry and tell
them you stop listening to my music
that'd be cool you don't listen to my
music all right federali actual says
between Tim cast and Luke cast my
Airwaves are filled with truth and
Liberty if only Rumble wasn't so buggy
stop being buggy Rumble also zipper
zipper tits is my new favorite word
that's from something isn't it so here's
a funny story we were at uh you know
that yeah well we were we were at uh uh
Hard Rock seminol in Miami and uh Jerry
Seinfeld was uh performing I guess so it
was nuts how crowded it was sold out
shows I guess and Alex Stein was there
so we're all hanging out and Alex Stein
is a crazy person so I I like playing $
five games that means like you bet $5
and then you get cards and you know like
minimal risk it's for fun we hang out we
sit down we go oh look at me I got Ace
King Alex is like come on man we got to
play $100 Blackjack let's go $100 per
pull slot machines you you film these
videos they go viral I'm like Alex I'm
not putting $100 in a slot machine for
one slot poll you're giving your money
away like let's play blackj $100 like no
I don't want to play this game it's too
much money and so he convinces us CU you
know we're we're weak will people I
guess but I thought it'd be funny to
like okay I'll take I'll take like 200
bucks we'll play $50 Blackjack and we
got destroyed by the like the dealer was
hitting 21 like crazy and so uh I was
like okay well like that's I I lost like
300 bucks
I don't want to play big hands like that
normally it's like you can play the the
the the lowest possible number and you
can play for a long time play craps $15
you'll you'll you'll play for an hour
off 30 bucks and then uh W over to one
table and it was like it's a $50 minimum
game and I forgot what game we were
playing I think it might have been um
man what was it I can't remember all I
know it came out to like 200 no it was
five oh it was
crisscross crisscross poker
and it was
$500 a hand because the minimum was it
no no it was $500 Max I think or I'm I'm
getting wrong basically if you bet $50
you have to bet it on two different
sides because it's crisscross there's
two hands that per game confusing
whatever okay and so I'm like okay I'll
I'll play like one hand maybe because
Alex wants to go crazy anyway that's not
the story the story is I hear some guy
behind me go whoa and I look I look back
and he's looking at like the stacks of
green chips and I was like yeah it's
like 500 at hand and he goes yeah and
then he and then Luke is sitting there
and then he just looks at his friend and
goes he goes on his show all the time
but he never goes on his show and then
we all started busting out laughing who
who's he pointing at he was he was he
was pointing at Luke saying he goes on
his show but he never goes on his show
and then all of us at the table and
everyone around started busting out
laughing like the people who knew who we
were and it was funny cuz like Luke goes
on IRL all the time but I never go on
Luke you got to go on the best political
show we're we wanted to get you on yeah
okay but to be fair like his show is new
I mean like they're doing good they're
doing real good it was funny that he
said it cuz like Luke does come on all
the time but anyway that was the story
uh but also it is a very very funny
story that Alex went crazy had no idea
what he was doing how to hit but he was
like come on man I'm watching these
videos on YouTube these guys are getting
like a 100,000 hits because they're
gambling all this money he's like Tim
when he puts the $100 in and hits the
button and it comes up jackpot I feel
like I got a jackpot and I was like okay
dude I don't want to spend money like
that but it was funny like Alex was
betting crazy amounts of money did he
win so he was doing really well at first
and he was up like a lot of money and
then he lost it all yep restraint that's
a big part of Victory he was he was
playing $100 hands and he was doing like
three Blackjack hands and he was he was
hitting it and I'm like he was on one
that night like for the first 10 minutes
we were all up like 500 bucks and then
the dealer couldn't lose after that he
just started hitting everything just
nonstop and then uh and then you know
Alex was like I've lost too much money I
think he wanted back though okay
actually I'm pretty sure he did we went
to he was like I want to go to the high
limit room and I was like oh jeez and
then he went and he bet like a bunch of
money on bakarat and hit and made a
bunch of money like I don't know dude
was wild he wasn't there for a long time
he was there for a good time you know I
could see him he like what's Tim we're
in Miami let's just play Let's just win
all this money we're here let's go can
you venmo me can you venmo me and I'll
give you give me the give me the cash
and I'll venmo you and I'm like dude
uh if you ever want to go to a casino
you need to go with Alex actually I just
tell you this hang out with Alex Stein
like f all I got to say up or down it's
the best just hang if you're if you're
if you're trying to laugh and get in
trouble or learn and have a deep
conversation he's all he's all that yeah
he's a funny guy like when the first
time he came here he ate the the one
chip challenge and got really sick two
ch ch all right all right all right
Julia Griffin says did you read
ragnaros one by Eric Jens definitely the
most relevant new Civil War Book right
now the ending gave me chills I've not
even heard of it not even heard of
it so here's one from the sigp says
there's chatter of Tucker facing a
travel ban sanction facing travel ban
sanctions for interviewing Putin if
that's true he could just walk through
the southern border with fingers held
high George alexopoulos drew that up
already and it's uh it's Dan khaw and I
think Graham being like he got the
interview we have to stop him and then
the next panel is them being is like
Biden being told Tucker already managed
to get back into the country then the
next panel is like the border and then
it shows Tucker smiling and he's running
through with a bunch of illegal
immigrants is very good GE G Prime was
it g Prime 8585 g g Prim 85 on on
Instagram very very good very funny very
funny let's go Ezekiel says what do you
think about the story Crowder released
about the possible school shooting
Wisconsin that was covered
up well uh interesting we need to go
we'll go through it we'll talk about it
on the members only show because there
were documents released and it's pretty
big it was like what was it it was like
a leftist I guess like woke ideologies
and uh we will we will talk about that
in the members only show in a couple
minutes so head over to
timcast.net
all right where we
at beep beep says curious what your
thoughts are on the channel 5 dude being
arrested for crossing the border oh is
that what actually happened I was I was
watching this today uh uh I forget his
actual name but he had a lot of uh uh
controversy earlier this year about his
personal character traits um but yeah he
went across the border he lited with
like some coyotes and just uh the whole
thing yeah and they arrested I didn't
know that part I only watched like till
like the first like first 10 minutes but
yeah I guess you got arrest it that's
crazy wow Mike Gibson says Rush limbo
used to say that you can always tell
what the left his planning based on the
accusations they make of their
opposition I mean he's not he was not
wrong was not wrong on that one no Lurch
says Trump supporters take him seriously
but not literally haters take him
literally but not seriously that's what
that that's what happened in 2016 the
Trump supporters were like Trump is
going to do these things he's a goofball
though he says things he just stand up
basically and the left were like he
literally wants to throw you know people
and flip them over and body slam them
and things like that and it's like oh
calm
down calm
down let's grab some more Super chats
Jake Beardsley says my son's
kindergarten class is teaching about
segregation and his best friend in
school got very upset because he thought
he couldn't be friends with my son
because he's white it's too young for
this stuff the school is Wellington
Elementary in
Florida well what's going on Florida
someone's got a got to tell Ronda santis
and have him get the job what's Ron
going to do you know he's out he's not
going to be Governor again he's term
limited maybe he's just going to retire
go into acting sort of reverse zalinski
his life I mean who's to say Thomas side
bottom says Pirates of the Caribbean wow
you made a good movie Pirates of the
Caribbean 2 wait you don't know what
made it good do you Pirates of the
Caribbean 3 yeah you had no idea I think
um if Pirates of the Caribbean was made
in the 7s it would be a Legendary
Classic with no sequels and they'd be
like man what a great movie but it was
made in a time when they were like more
money and uh what I loved about it when
the commercials came out for Dead Man's
Chest it was like the number one movie
in the country and I was like no Pirates
of the Caribbean one is the number one
movie in the country and people are
going to see your garbage movie because
of how much they liked the first one and
when I went and saw the second one I was
like this is garbage this sucks I've
still haven't seen any of them and it's
because there was a lot of Pop trash
getting created at that time and it just
looked like another pop trash where
everyone's like I love it it's so great
like Harry Potter the movie fine
whatever it wasn't horrible but I read
the book it was okay I saw the movie it
was decent the first Pirates is is is is
utterly fantastic like Jack Sparrow
wasn't supposed to be like that he was
supposed to be like a normal pirate and
then Johnny Depp was like let's make him
a bit eccentric and kind of drunk all
the time and so they gave him an
original character to work with and he
made it better right the I mean the
storyline is fantastic the the they they
looted the treasure they found the gold
but it was cursed and now they're all
Walking Dead and they're trying to
return the gold brilliant story and then
the next movie was like there's no
ending it's like there's a chest with
the heart in it and then the movie ends
and nothing happens and then the third
movie is like oh we resurrected the guy
who died in the first one so that story
made no sense and it's just you know I
think um dead men tell no Tales was was
decent nowhere near as good as the first
one but better than the rest was that
the fourth one I don't know maybe that
was the fifth one see I only remember
the first maybe two but I also remember
them vividly because I saw them in
theater and I think now this like oh
we're going to release a bunch of stuff
in the Netflix era is very different
like the experience of watching like
seeing if you haven't seen Pirates of I
don't know what to tell you but the the
scene when they're on the deck and the
Moonlight comes through and like that
the pirate crew is skeletons like I
remember that so vividly in that
experience in surround sound uh I really
think moving to streaming is one of the
things that's changing the way make
movies today yeah and it's it's it's
killing the movie starh you know I'm I
like I'm on Netflix or Amazon and
there's a movie and it's like they make
fun of Gina corano because they said the
movie she's starting with daily wire
domestic gross is in the tens of
thousands and it's like right it it was
it wasn't a movie in theaters it's a
it's a streaming platform film nobody
talks about the you know what's the oh
Netflix put out a new movie how much did
it make we don't know n Netflix puts out
like 50 movies every month it feels I
know they literally do all right uh last
Super Chat here here Ash says your next
big song release needs to star in and be
all about graphine well the next release
is coming out in a couple weeks and it
does star in it's called eyes of advice
and uh we we did a little pre a 30-
second preview on uh the timcast members
only which we're going to now so smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel head over to
timcast.net RL you can follow me
personally at timcast Natalie do you
want to shout anything up I'm scared for
the show now um you can follow me at
Natalie G Winters and if you want to
look at the entirely usamade clothing
brand for men and women you can go to
she's so
right. and check it out it's been a
blast designing it and a lot of the
stuff has sold out but the pre-orders
are coming back in stock in the next few
days that's awesome it's been fun having
you here thank you I'm Hannah clear brim
I'm a writer for cnr.com that's scanner
news you can follow all of our work at
timcast news on Twitter and Instagram if
you want to follow me personally I'm on
Instagram at H.B and I'm on Twitter at
hcmo guys thank you so much thank you
for everything you guys do good to see
you it was quite a pleasure always great
good to see you guys on TV here at home
uh have a great night take care of
yourself be good to yourself call your
mom it was my mom's birthday to I ow a
phone call no makeup happy birthday
Becky yeah and wipe off that makeup
you're beautiful as you are nice I like
that really wholesome uh shout out to
Ian's mom too happy birthday as well um
I am surge.com I'm excited for this
after show uh it'll be fun thank you for
coming Natalie as always uh let's uh get
to it we will see you all over at
timcast.net